Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Moin Leute, Zack, nice, Funst.
weiß man aber windows sounds letztendlich nie
wartet mal ich bin gleich wieder da
Und dann ist es fertig.
So, meine Güte.
Vater ruft zum fünften Mal heute an oder so.
Der Frazier.
Tja, ich weiß nicht, was der gerade so treibt.
Unsicher.
Ich habe vor einem halben Jahr oder so zuletzt was gehört vom Fabian.
Das scheint alles zu funktionieren.
Ich habe jetzt bisher nichts mehr gehört von irgendwelchen Problemen, die er da mit seinem Computer hat.
Wilder Igel, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Ich haue ja auch nicht ab.
Ich bin ja erst seit 1 Minute 32 und Massive Subscription.
Dankeschön.
Nee, nee, der kommt mit seinem Linux wohl ganz gut klar.
dem habe ich ja linux mint installiert denn rock sang schon 53 jahre massive
mit live crisis gestartet danke für den sub
was du noch youtube videos ja ja ich habe nicht vor mir youtube aufzuhören
ich kann kann ich genauso wie ich nicht für nicht viel schrieben kann
ab grad gesundheitlich etwas probleme aber die letzten letzten stream schon
erzählen was sache ist
du gehst jetzt raus wie in irl oder was das aber gefährlich weißt du oder
ja ich weiß ich weiß ich habe lange nichts hochgeladen
jolo ja ja anders geht es ja auch nicht aber kurz meine vm an und eine runde
eine runde package updates was sind das ach so das ist die die secure boot geschichte was wir
letzten ausprobiert habe ich wurde habe ich hier eine secure keck wwm habe ja ja mache ich mache
ich du sitzt auf dem kreisberg und höre stream und dabei tippst du nicht schlecht hast du hast
du text to speech nicht schlecht hast du denn für ein kreisberg wenn man fragen darf
hast du secure boot auf dem haus mittlerweile aktivieren habe nicht aber ich doch nicht ich
habe so nicht mal ausprobiert nach dem stream ich habe sie ausprobiert
ja gestern konnte ich keine aufwachen stream machen hätte mich zu sehr zwingen müssen dazu
aber das wird in zukunft auch wieder besser kannst du mal wieder stellen ja mache ich
mache ich sowohl auf youtube als auch hier on stream sobald ich da wieder den
kopf für hat mache ich das dasselbe wie du background du hast zwei mal zwölf
nice das neuere salz ich habe zwar ich habe zwei mal elf noch mehr ich habe
auch das carbon back road aber noch zwei mal elf die i2 2 x 11
Ihr habt jetzt aber nicht alle Rose-Bikes gekauft, weil ich die mal ein paar Mal im Stream gezeigt habe.
Wenn ja, muss ich mir unbedingt hier Sponsorship klar machen.
Ja, warte.
Dann wäre ich wahrscheinlich der einzige Technik-Streamer mit sowas.
Ne, dazu müsste ich selbst erstmal wieder ein bisschen mehr Fahrrad fahren.
dazu müsste ich echt mal wieder ein bisschen mich selbst ein bisschen öfters draufsetzen ich
habe jetzt bestimmt schon zwei monate oder so kein fahrrad mehr gefahren
und auch kaum gejoggt das merkt man ich bin wahrscheinlich komplett untrainiert jetzt naja
untrainiert nicht. Nicht so wie früher.
Aber wahrscheinlich hab ich ganz schön
abgebaut.
Du hast auch 2x11, ja dann. Nice.
Ja, die 2x12 gibt's ja jetzt auch
erst. Das neue Backroad
ist mega nice mit dem USB-Anschluss
und so. Aber
erstens saumäßig teuer und
ich hab
keinen Bock
mir für 4.500 Euro ein neues
Fahrrad zu kaufen, obwohl das alte noch top in Ordnung
ist und eigentlich auch vollkommen ausreichend
dein klapprad ist auseinandergebrochen shit happens
ich muss gerade mal in die e mails gucken wartet mal gucken ob die das
gesehen haben ja okay gut ihr termin wurde storniert sehr schön
wir haben es gesehen
wenn es keine ersatzteile es gibt doch eigentlich für fahrrad
ersatzteile gibt es doch quasi online shops noch und löcher
was sei denn das irgendwas proprietär ist was irgendwie nur vom hersteller
gab und den hersteller gibt es nicht mehr
grüße aus dem gym ihr seid alle so sportlich gerade da kriege ich ein
richtig schlechtes gewissen dass ich in letzter zeit kaum was gemacht habe
wobei ich hatte andere probleme ich habe eine gute ausrede weil ich nichts
gemacht habe mal gucken können wir uns dann gleich mal anschauen hier
der hype ums rennradeln da sind wir doch beim thema da wäre ich bestimmt
getriggert bei so einem Video,
weil es wieder darum geht, also höchstwahrscheinlich,
so wie das in vielen Zeitungen
stattfindet, so nach dem Motto,
die ganz bösen, schlimmen
Fahrradfahrer, die rasen immer so
und sind immer so rücksichtslos
und wenn man sich das mal vergleicht mit dem, was
da mit Autos passiert, ist das halt der
absolute Witz dagegen.
Von der Gefährlichkeit her, ja.
Heißt jetzt nicht,
dass man rücksichtslos fahren sollte,
aber das wird, finde ich,
total überzogen oftmals dargestellt.
So nach dem Motto, als hätte jeder Rennfahrer mindestens 5 Fußgänger auf dem Gewissen oder so.
Was ein kompletter Schwachsinn ist.
Aber gucken wir mal, vielleicht ist der Beitrag gar nicht so.
Ich ahne nur, ich ahne nur schon Schlimmes, ey.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch hier?
What my smart home was missing.
Okay, so ein Vault-Tablet.
Naja gut, Vault.
Okay, jetzt müssen wir mal checken, Leute.
Ist das ein Kokona-Video?
Ich ahne es, wenn ich die Wand sehe, wenn ich die Wand sehe, sieht das so ein bisschen nach Kona-Wand aus.
Also, wer bescheuerte Twitch-Speak nicht versteht, was man da keinem übel nehmen kann.
Ich meine damit, das ist eine Holzwand, wie bei den Amis üblich.
Aber schauen wir mal.
Okay, okay.
Ja
Ey, der sägt
Pass mal auf, der sägt Löcher in die Wand
Das ist, das ist wieder, ja, ja, ja, ja
Da weißt du schon Bescheid, okay
Das geht auch noch bei
Na, wobei, das könnte auch
Irgend so eine Gipswand sein, wie bei uns manche
Zwischendrin haben, also
Es ist einfach so, es ist nicht 100%ig
Kakaoner Wand, aber
die, die sehen eher nach einer Gipswand aus, oder?
Aber die Chancen sind
doch schon recht hoch, würde ich sagen.
Ich habe auch eine Gipswand hier.
Bei mir ist hier, warte mal.
Was war das?
Was hat denn der Auto completed gerade?
Habt ihr das gesehen?
Irgendwas hat der gerade Auto completed.
Server, Raum.
3D.
Das hier, man sieht es ja hier gleich, wenn ich da reingehe.
Oh nee, jetzt lädt YouTube wieder nicht, weil ich mir Werbung auf meinen eigenen Videos angucken muss und der Adblocker wieder rumbackt.
Beziehungsweise liegt er nicht wirklich...
Was habe ich denn hier? Ah, Mittagessen.
So, das hier, das ist auch eine Gipswand.
Und ich bin immer noch nicht auf die Idee gekommen, einfach mal ein Loch reinzuschneiden, um ein Tablet einzubauen.
Hm.
Jetzt, wenn ich es mir so recht überlege...
Vielleicht wird es Zeit.
Schon mal die Säge rausholen.
Ups.
Ne, ne, ich schneide kein Loch in meine Gipswand rein.
Das ist, wo das Internet lebt.
das internet lebt in einer fritz box ja wie in deiner auch dachte das internet
gibt es nur bei mir was ist das gibt es das internet mehrfach so ich es auf
Universal Remote.
Ja.
Da muss, ja klar, da muss einem die Bude gehören,
wenn du Löcher in die Wand schneidest. Das stimmt
wohl.
Das Internet gibt's auf der Hanauer Landstraße
in Frankfurt, richtig.
Ich glaube, das ist eines der wenigen Orte
auf der Welt, wo man echt sagen kann, hier
ist das Internet.
Zumindest ein nicht
ist. Ein sehr wichtiger
Teil des Internets
ist in Frankfurt auf der Hanauer Landstraße.
DZX, ja, genau.
Moment.
Kurze Hacker-Mode starten.
Alles klar.
Chat, ich hoffe, ihr seid drin.
Seid ihr in Hacker-Stimmung?
Schon längst?
Ach, stimmt, stimmt.
Die Frage ist eigentlich schon zu viel gewesen.
Natürlich seid ihr drin.
Reverse Shell connected.
Alles gut.
Jetzt weiß ich Bescheid.
Chat ist wieder auf.
Zack.
Einfach Pfeif hätte der Chat.
Ihr habt die Reverse Shell schon offen,
bevor der Port offen ist.
Okay.
Ja, in Deutschland ist das Single Paint of Fail...
Single Paint vor allem.
Single Point of Failure.
Weil da die beiden Leitungen nur 100 Meter auseinander sind.
Das wusste ich gar nicht.
Ist das so?
Also ich weiß, dass es da schon öfters mal kleine Probleme gegeben hat.
die dann auch Auswirkungen hatten auf das Internet.
Aber, also, ich habe zumindest noch nichts gehört von irgendwelchen Leitungen.
Es war in Frankfurt, gab es mal vor einem Jahr oder so,
gab es Probleme in einem Teil der Stadt bei Business Enterprise Anbindungen,
weil da irgendein Bagger die Glasfaserleitung durchgebaggert hat.
Ja, machen wir. Wir machen alle neue Set-Servers.
dass sobald das endlich so gemacht ist,
wir müssten mal gucken, ich weiß gar nicht,
ob das mittlerweile vielleicht schon so ist,
dass man sich nicht mehr einfach
remote da drauf connecten kann.
Er hat geschrieben, dass er es gefixt hat?
Echt?
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr genau, was das Problem war.
Es gab doch zwei Probleme.
Einmal, dass wenn man die ganze URL hatte,
ging's.
Und wir hatten doch zuletzt noch ein anderes Problem.
Was war das denn nochmal? Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr.
IP-Leak.
Ah.
Ja.
Battlefield 6, ja, wenn Battlefield 6 rauskommt, mach ich was.
Ich weiß, ich weiß, aber der einzige D-Sticks, wo ich drin war, war der von Interaction.
Auf der Hanauer Landstraße.
Bei den anderen Standorten war ich noch nicht.
Und ich glaube, die anderen Standorte sind auch nicht so groß.
Wie der auf der Hanauer Landstraße.
an straße aber ich weiß dass es mehrere gibt irgendwie durch nummeriert sind
schon wieder sonntag ja es ist schon wieder sonntag woche
es gibt fast vor ort
du willst mich du willst mich nicht verleiten zu c++ flame oder kann das
sein oder war das ein guter roll kommt hat beides bedeuten er mache ich weiß ich habe
jetzt auch dafür gesorgt dass ich das spiel wenigsten spielen kann wegen secure boot konnte
ich die beta ja nicht spielen aber jetzt jetzt müsste es gehen c++ ist besser als peifen wo
wir gerade dabei sind irgendwie würde mir hier in den remote in den riemen ich kann ja mal reden
ein video empfohlen ist ich habe es nicht aufgemacht was denn sie blass blass ok keine
ahnung ich finde es nicht mehr es wurde wurde mir eben gerade als als forscher angezeigt hier
Ich habe keine Ahnung, um was es da geht.
Aber ich habe nur den Titel gelesen.
Okay, der ist ja schon ein bisschen älter, der weiß.
Der war da live dabei.
Ich habe nur den Titel gelesen.
Und da habe ich mir gedacht, es gibt wirklich was, das noch schlimmer ist.
Und noch benutzt wird.
Ich meine, klar, wenn du mal zurück gehst.
Und manchmal sich sowas wie Kobol oder Fortran oder irgendwie...
Ja, sicherlich geht es immer noch schlimmer.
Aber von allen aktuell benutzten Programmiersprachen, die eine gewisse nennenswerte Verbreitung haben, ist C++ das Schlimmste.
Visual Basic benutzt auch kein Mensch mehr, oder?
Meint ihr, Visual Basic hat noch eine nennenswerte Verbreitung?
Und ich rede jetzt nicht von irgendwelchen Meme-Programmiersprachen wie Brainfuck oder sowas.
Meint ihr wirklich?
Also ja, es gibt in Office, gibt es diese VBA-Geschichte.
Aber das ist ja damit nicht...
Ja, ja gut, das würde ich als eigenes zählen.
So schlimm ist das doch auch nicht, oder?
Also es kann nicht schlimmer als C++ sein.
Erlang. Erlang ist auch wild, das stimmt.
Ich vermute, dass das hier...
Dass das gültige Erlang-Code ist, meint ihr?
Das könnte sein, oder?
Also ich glaube, das ist valid.
vielleicht noch ein paar eckige klammern und ein paar geschweifte so also vor allem runde
klammern ich glaube dass ich glaube dass es wäre der lang code und mal gucken er lang
parter online hier ich habe block insel das sind irgendwelche shady seiten keine ahnung
Ich wollte das mal reinpasten und checken.
Du kannst Überschriften
in Word formatieren. Krass.
Massive.
Und das ohne
Prime-Subscription.
Habe ich nicht für möglich gehalten.
Was ist das da?
Borderlands 4. Da gibt es ein
Twitch-Icon.
Haben sich wieder was kosten lassen hier.
Ja, Borderlands 4 ist auch so ein Ding, Leute.
Hat das jemand von euch gekauft und gespielt?
Ich habe sie mir nicht gekauft. Ich bin ja richtiger Borderlands-Fan.
Ich habe es mir nicht gekauft, weil ich gelesen habe, also eines der ersten News, die ich gelesen habe, war, Performance ist richtig beschissen.
Da habe ich mir gedacht, ich habe keinen Bock mit meiner 4090 und meinem nicht so ganz schlechten PC, da irgendwie mit 50 FPS rumzukrebsen.
Ist mega geil eigentlich, Performance ist Arsch.
Ja, genau, so dachte ich mir das, so dachte ich mir das aus.
sollte auf deinem system also ich habe leute gesehen die haben 50 90 160 fps ich weiß ja
auch nicht genau was die für was die für grafik settings hatten ja wenn man wenn man mit den
grafik settings also was ich halt überhaupt nicht mag ist ki frame generierung alles alles was input
lag erzeugt, gibt es bei mir nicht.
Alles aus.
Dann lieber niedrigere Details.
KI-Frame-Generierung mag ich nicht.
Fake Frames.
Ja, ist es ja letztendlich.
Also, mal realistisch
betrachtet, bei Singleplayer-Games
geht das eigentlich schon voll in Ordnung.
Ich habe das auch mal testweise
bei Max Payne
Alan Wake 2
hatte ich das auch testweise an
und
das war erstaunlich
gut, man hat da gar nicht wirklich viel Input-Lag
bemerkt.
In dem Singleplayer-Game
war es eh schon nicht sonderlich schnell, das muss man sagen.
Alan Wake war ja
quasi Third Party,
relativ langsam alles. Aber ich könnte
mir vorstellen,
wenn man damit beispielsweise
irgendwie was Schnelles spielt,
oder muss ja nichts schnelles sein. Irgendwas mit,
wo es wirklich auf Input-Lag-Reaktion
zählt, sowas wie CS oder
früher haben die Leute sowas wie Quake noch
gespielt oder
Overwatch oder sowas. Ich glaube
oder Fortnite oder einfach alles, was du halbwegs
Apex, alles was du halbwegs
Competitive spielen kannst, kann ich mir
nicht vorstellen, dass Frame-Generierung
wirklich so geil ist.
Wie die Latenz ändert sich damit nicht.
Äh.
Na klar ändert sich die Latenz.
Stell dir mal vor,
jetzt stell dir mal vor,
du hast die Auswahl zwischen
Super Optik
und 50S echten FPS
und mit KI-Frame-Generierung
hast du dann 120 FPS.
Versus echte 120 FPS
mit niedrigerer Qualität.
So, und jetzt überleg mal,
woran soll die KI-Frame-Generierung
wissen, dass gerade
ein Gegner
in dieser Millisekunde,
wo das Paket reinkommt, quasi
den Kopf um die Ecke steckt.
Das weiß die KI-Frame-Generierung
nicht. Das weiß die KI-Frame-Generierung
erst,
wenn es auch wirklich
ankommt. Und dann
mit dem nächsten Frame kannst du das generieren.
Ja, aber es kommt doch aufs Gleiche raus.
Übrigens weiß ich gar nicht, wie oft da irgendwas brechen wird.
Also im Prinzip kann ja der Fake Frame keine Informationen haben, die es noch nicht gibt.
Oder die das Game noch nicht verarbeitet hat, so muss man es eigentlich sagen.
Geht ja nicht, woher soll das die KI wissen?
Oh, mit 100. Also echte FPS sind auf jeden Fall besser als Fake-FPS.
Ach, Quatsch. Das haben sie doch schon vor drei Jahren.
Leute, wer erinnert sich noch, wo wir gerade wieder Klausi...
Wer erinnert sich noch an...
Wer erinnert sich noch an Stadia, hä?
hups eigentlich wollte ich mario gar nicht zeigen ich wollte hier hin stadia
alter
was anderes fällt mir da nicht ein so war alles ist bald der cloud ich weiß
ich weiß dass du es nicht ernst gemeint hast aber ich bin gerade wieder
eingefallen dabei
Was ist denn das?
ASCIIXF.
Was ist das? Was habe ich da?
Upload Download Files using the ASCII-Protokoll.
What?
Ich habe am besten gar keine Ahnung.
Was das eigentlich sein soll.
Egal, ASCII-Aquarium ist eh das Beste.
Kann man sogar vorspulen mittlerweile, Leute.
das ist das ist mittlerweile richtig das ist die etwa anste ask aquarium version
daher mit vorspulen button ja next big thing in gaming da haben sie sich ein
ab haben sie sich abgefeiert könnt ihr euch noch daran erinnern wie sie bei
stadia erzählt haben negativ lädt sie weil die leute gesagt haben wir
wie ist es denn mit Input-Lag und kann man damit
auch gescheit Competitive Games spielen?
Und wo die dann erzählt haben, ja, wir haben sogar
Negativ-Latency.
Kann man echt nur
Nope-Champen
oder wie auch immer das immer auch heißt.
Ja, das wäre mal was.
Ask Iquario mit generierten
KI-Frames. Da bin ich mal gespannt,
wie gut das das hinkriegen würde, wahrscheinlich gar nicht.
Super Tabs, ja,
finde ich auch hier, das ist so, wie es
sein soll.
Ja, und die Begründung,
ich erzähle das jetzt nochmal, weil das weiß wahrscheinlich
nicht mal jeder, was da für ein Pult ist, kann sich auch keiner
merken, aber in dem Fall habe ich es mir gemerkt.
Die Begründung für
Negative Latency bei
Stadia
war,
dass es ja sein kann,
dass die Leute auf einem Server spielen,
der bei Google steht.
Und dementsprechend ist die Latenz
ja von Google zum Server viel geringer,
wie wenn die von daheim zum Server gehen würden.
Dass natürlich immer noch das Bild ankommen
muss und der Input gestreamt werden muss,
ist ja egal.
Aber negativ vielleicht
in C.
Ich muss ja sagen, bei einer Sache
da war ich ja sehr skeptisch
und zwar was den Breitbandausbau
in Deutschland angeht
aber
ich kann euch das jetzt nicht belegen
mit Zahlen, da müsste ich mal suchen, ob es da wirklich
jetzt auch schon, weil das soll ja so ein
so ein
ich hab vergessen wie das heißt
irgendein Logbuch oder sowas in der Richtung
wollten die ja einführen, dass man quasi auch
wirklich kontrollieren kann,
werden denn die Breitbandziele erreicht?
Keine Ahnung, wie es da eigentlich aussieht. Aber ich muss sagen,
gefühlt läuft der
Breitbandausbau echt nicht schlecht.
Egal, wo du rumfährst
und wo du guckst und
wo du was siehst,
siehst du eigentlich irgendwelche Bauarbeiten
an den Straßen, wo
wahrscheinlich, ja,
irgendwelche Glasfaser und Internetsachen verlegt werden.
Also,
Da scheint er ganz gut zu laufen.
Ich muss euch noch was sagen, Leute.
Ich glaube,
hat er nicht mitgekriegt, aber
ich hatte heute, also
nur mal kurz für die Leute, die letzten
Stream nicht da waren.
Ich habe ja gerade ein bisschen psychische Probleme, habe ich euch ja im letzten Stream erzählt.
Und ich mache ja seit November einmal in der Woche gehe ich zu einer Therapie.
Also.
Und ich hatte heute Gespräch mit dem Psychologen.
Und ich habe dann bei dem einen, was er gefragt hat, habe ich gesagt, nee, nee, keck L.
Ich glaube das hat er nicht richtig verstanden
Aber gut ich mein
Wenn der nicht gestörte leute gewöhnt ist wer dann
der lässt sich nicht vergehen ja
Ja, das steht bestimmt in meiner Akte jetzt mit drin.
Redet wie Riddichi Maus.
Wäre geil, wenn er Lull geantwortet hätte, ja.
Omega Lull, ja.
Ja wisst ihr eigentlich, dass das heute Therapiestream ist?
Ich hab heute wieder so einen Tag, wo ich mir voll viele Gedanken gemacht hab
Und da hab ich mir gedacht, da machst du einfach Nachmittag Stream an
Und da kommst du auf andere Gedanken
Ich glaube, das ist auch
Weltweit bisher undokumentierter Fall
Twitch als Therapieplattform
Weiß der Therapeut, dass du streamst?
ja ja das ist ein pp gabi sie traten keck weh ja genau da war ich noch drauf
ja weiß er weiß sogar dass ich youtube videos mache schaut dazu sein kann ich
mir nicht vorstellen ist auch ganz gut so
da käme ich mir irgendwie blöd vor keine ahnung was das der vm champ
wobei kein also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass der weiß also der weiß dass ich strebe
und er weiß auch dass youtube videos mache aber da war es weder den den twitch channel
noch den YouTube-Channel.
Kek L.
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum.
Das war mir so danach. Kek L, wollte ich einfach
sagen. Kek L.
Kek L.
Das wär's.
Das sind wir so rausgerutscht. Das hat er, glaube ich, gar nicht gehört.
Da hatten wir gerade Verbindungsprobleme.
Weiß nicht, woran das lag, ob ein WLAN im Arsch war oder so.
Egal.
So sieht's aus.
Ja, ich bin echt froh, dass ich da die Tabletten gut vertrage.
Seitdem geht's auch alles schon wieder viel besser.
Sonst würde ich gar nicht auf die Idee kommen, zu keckellen.
Machst du, achso, du machst das online, taugt das was?
Ich mach das online und offline
Also ich war auch schon offline
In einer psychologischen, psychiatrischen Einrichtung
Und Therapie mache ich aber zum größten Teil online
Einfach aus dem Grund, weil ich ein fauler Sack bin
Und das Hauptsächliche ist, weil du ja keinen Platz findest in der Nähe.
Wobei ich sagen muss, das war eigentlich eher, das klingt krass dramatisch, naja.
Ja doch, also das letzte Dreivierteljahr war schon für mich relativ dramatisch in der Richtung.
Aber glücklicherweise geht es seit ich jetzt seit, ja ungefähr Anfang August, nehme ich ein paar Pillen gegen meine Probleme und seitdem ist es tatsächlich besser.
Ich habe zwar immer noch so ein paar Tage so richtige Durchhänge, also ich habe keine Depressionen oder so, kann ich gleich dazu sagen.
So ein paar Durchhänge, wo ich mir irgendwie super viel Gedanken mache um alles mögliche.
Und das war echt schwierig ein bisschen in den Griff zu kriegen.
Aber seitdem ich die Pillen nehme ist gut.
Oder viel besser zumindest.
Ich habe immer noch so ein paar Tage Durchhänge.
Heute ist wieder so ein Tag, wo ich mir echt viel Gedanken mache.
Da habe ich mir gedacht, ich mache jetzt einfach Stream an.
Das bringt mich auf andere Gedanken.
Aufwahl, ey, danke schön für den Sub.
Prox Subscription, fauler Sack, so real, ja.
Ja, ja.
Wie du einen Therapieplatz gefunden hast oder zahlst du es privat?
Ich bin privat versichert.
Ja.
Ich hab das online gesucht, den Platz.
Den Therapieplatz.
Ich hab das online gesucht und hab da auch
einen echt guten Therapeut gefunden.
Ziemlich schnell.
Was halt nice ist.
Aber
genug von dem Thema jetzt.
Könntest du ja mit dem Fahrrad hinfahren.
Ne, das ist ein bisschen zu weit weg.
Ah, den Reffling.
Kann ich mal fragen ich hab da interessenten
Kek L
Rev Code Kek L
Ayaya
So dass ASCII Aquarium mal ausgeschaltet werden
Achso Leute
Nachdem es letztes Mal ja immer
Manche auch von euch gesagt haben
Sie haben da auch Probleme und sowas in der Richtung
Also ich sag so
Ich will jetzt nicht
Dass zum Hauptthema irgendwie
Dass es zum Hauptthema von einem Stream wird
Für eine Stunde oder so
Aber ich habe auch nichts dagegen
Wenn ihr mich dazu was fragen wollt
Also ich bin mittlerweile
Da so weit
Dass ich da auch drüber reden kann
Also wenn ihr da auch irgendwas habt und vielleicht was wissen wollt
Also könnt ihr mich ruhig fragen.
Aber wohlgemerkt, ich habe da keine Qualifikation zu, außer dass ich selbst betroffen bin, was das Thema Angststörung angeht.
Außer dass ich selbst betroffen bin, habe ich keine Qualifikation dazu, was zu sagen.
Und eins kann ich euch dazu sagen, es ist keine Schande, zu sagen, man kriegt selbst nicht mehr auf die Reihe und zu gucken, wer einem helfen kann.
Weil manche Sachen kriegt man einfach selbst nicht mehr auf die Reihe. Und das ist nicht schlimm, weil wir sind halt glücklicherweise in keinem dritten Weltland, wo es nichts gibt an Infrastruktur. Wir haben ja die Möglichkeiten.
Ja, aber ich bin wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr lange privat krankenversichert, weil bei mir auf der Arbeit ein großer Block Rufbereitschaft nicht mehr da ist.
Dementsprechend muss ich mich wahrscheinlich wieder gesetzlich versichern.
Ist aber nicht schlimm.
Man kann ja die Option da drauf behalten.
Ja.
Hast du ihn freiwillig abgegeben?
Mehr oder weniger, ja.
Einfach, ja gut, freiwillig kann man nicht sagen.
Ja doch.
Mehr oder weniger freiwillig.
Ja, das macht enorm viel aus.
Man darf nicht vergessen, ich arbeite ja sogar nur vier Tage die Woche.
Also das kommt ja auch noch dabei.
Ja, naja.
Da sind bestimmt...
Ja, knapp 20.000 Euro oder so weniger.
Aber wurscht.
Was hältst du von Cloud Gaming, GeForce Now?
GeForce Now habe ich nie ausprobiert.
Ne, ne Quatsch.
Mal gucken was sie sich da in Zukunft ausdenken, wie man das machen oder was wir uns da in
Zukunft ausdenken, was man machen kann.
Mal schauen.
finde ich gar nicht so schlecht.
Gerade in den Zeiten, wo ich so Probleme hatte zu schlafen.
So ging es ja los.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, kann ich auch nur unterstreichen,
Therapie hilft wirklich.
Glaubt das am Anfang gar nicht, man denkt, es kann einem keiner helfen.
Doch, das
hält man erst, wenn man es mal ausprobiert hat.
Also man hält das vorher gar nicht für möglich.
Und das ist auf jeden Fall auch keine Schande, mal beispielsweise in die Ambulanz zu fahren von irgendeiner psychiatrischen Klinik oder so,
weil man selbst gar nicht mehr auf die Reihe kriegt und zu sagen, Leute, ey, ich weiß nicht weiter.
Ihr seid nicht die einzigen, die sowas haben. Es gibt viel mehr Leute, als man denkt, die psychische Probleme haben.
Vor allem war mir auch nicht klar, ist das in Bürojobs und gerade in der IT tatsächlich viel verbreiteter, als man denkt.
Glaubt man gar nicht, ne?
Denkt man sich, was soll da Schlimmes sein?
Gechillt vorm Rechner sitzen, viel Homeoffice haben, kann doch nichts Schlimmes sein.
Ja, aber anscheinend neigen Leute, die in der IT arbeiten, auch ein bisschen zu mentalen Problemen.
also wie auch immer das zusammenhängt keine ahnung
das stimmt man muss da schon mit dem gut klarkommen so aber also wie gesagt wenn
ihr was wissen wollte fragen könnt ihr könnt ihr immer erzählen ich bin mittlerweile mittlerweile
bin ich in einem start status wo ich sage mir eigentlich tut es mir ganz gut bis drüber zu
reden deswegen ist das nicht wild so speed dating experience dann hat er
mal wieder fall der stelle für so also was gucken wir ja wo ist eine network
chuck hallo wo ist er denn jetzt blöd wusste
Ach ne, da ist er doch.
Ich bin ja blöd, äh.
Ich hab ihn ja nicht gesehen.
Ey, gut.
Das ist es bei mir nicht, aber
kann ich mir gut vorstellen.
Ja.
Du könntest nie Homeoffice machen.
Das Büro ist so schön leer.
Homeoffice-Beste.
Das stimmt wohl, ja.
Es gab ja auch mal so eine Umfrage,
dass, ich krieg's nicht mal genau zusammen,
dass irgendwie,
glaub ich, ein Drittel der Leute
in Bürojobs innerlich
quasi schon gekündigt hat.
Auch, ehrlich, auch krasse Statistik, ne?
Wenn man sich das überlegt,
also, innerlich heißt das so nach dem Motto,
die, denen fehlt noch
der äußere Impuls quasi so,
um wirklich zu kündigen, aber die haben eigentlich schon
keinen Bock mehr und werden da auch jederzeit
bereit zu. Das heißt, wenn die einer
versucht abzuwerben, sind die,
das sind quasi die, wo auch viele solcher
Recruiting-Sachen halt
drauf abzielen,
so mit Werbung auf Reddit oder
auf LinkedIn und sowas, um den Leuten, die
innerlich quasi schon weg sind
bei ihrem aktuellen Arbeitgeber,
die dazu zu überzeugen, ja, geh doch mal
woanders hin.
Ja okay dann ist ja nicht schlimm dann muss
dann
besser so besser so als jemand der voll drin ist und freut auf morgen erfährt er hier tschüss
gut wir haben ja fristen ist ja nicht wirklich von aber
aber vielen zeichnen sich wahrscheinlich auch schon
Ob das die sind die auch gut beim job sind das kann man glaube ich gar nicht so sagen es gibt viele gute leute
die einfach von abläufen prozessen oder oder keine ahnung auch kollegen und chefs und sonst
was so demotiviert sind dass die eigentlich richtig gute sache machen könnten aber in
dieser aktuellen position nicht ich habe letztens meinem chef erzählt dass der beste chef den ich
hier hatte und das ganz ohne zu schleimen
also da muss ich echt sagen dort wo ich aktuell bin die wählen also beim letzten
arbeitgeber war das so ich hoffe das hat ihn zumindest ein bisschen bestärkt in
dem wasser bei meinem letzten arbeitgeber war so jeder dabei drei
nicht auf dem baum ist wurde führungskraft ich war bei drei immer
auf dem baum und dementsprechend kurzer halbwertszeit hatten die leute auch und
Und bei meinem aktuellen Arbeitgeber ist es so, okay, wenn du das werden möchtest, kannst du dich vorher schon mal mit der Thematik auseinandersetzen, bis es dann soweit ist.
Dementsprechend werden das zum größten Teil auch nur Leute, die das wollen und auch dafür geeignet sind.
Quiet Quitting, genau.
Aber dann wurde das Produkt ausgerechnet so geändert, dass ich nicht mehr damit... Ja, solche Sachen, ja.
So, dann gucken wir uns doch mal hier das Video an.
Vom Network-Chuck.
Warum sollte man Chef werden wollen?
Ich persönlich verstehe das auch nicht, aber es gibt Leute, die gehen da voll auf drin.
Hat jeder seine Stärken und Vorlieben.
ich kann es mir auch nicht vorstellen
ich würde im Leben nicht Teamleiter werden
wollen, Teamleiter ist ja, wenn man es mal genau nimmt
glaube ich die
anspruchsvollste
kann man vielleicht nicht sagen
das ist das falsche Wort
mir fällt kein richtiges
Wort ein, was ich aber sagen
will ist, als Teamleiter hast du
halt das Problem, du kriegst von deinen
Leuten das Gemaule ab und du kriegst
von deinem Chef das Gemäule ab. Du bist quasi
so in der Zange.
Das passiert bei
Stellen oben drüber immer weniger.
Da kriegst du
vornehm von einer Seite das
Gemecker ab.
Aber bei Teamleiter oder
Gruppenleiter oder whatever man es
nennt, ja,
hast du halt das Ding, deine Leute
meckern die ganze Zeit und deine Chefs
meckern die ganze Zeit. Oder du musst dir das
Gemecker von deinen Chefs und deinen Leuten anhören.
Deswegen ist Teamleiter so das
wirklich das Schlimmste, was ich mir vorstellen könnte.
Moin.
Hat das eigentlich geklappt mit Veracrypt?
Also.
Es hat geklappt in der VM.
Hier in der da.
Selbst ausprobiert auf meinem
Rechner hab ich tatsächlich noch nicht.
Was eigentlich, warum ist
der Sound eigentlich aus? Achso, weil ich das Video
gucken wollte. Okay.
Dann schauen wir mal.
This is where the Internet lives.
Schauen wir mal, wo das Internet lebt.
Wenn nicht in Frankfurt auf der Hanauer Landstraße.
Was?
Oh mein Gott.
Die gibt's auch überall, oder?
Die gibt's auch überall.
Frankfurt Kleierstraße zum Beispiel gibt's die
Ähm, das
Tomatolix-Video zum Internet
Ich glaube, das haben wir mal
zusammen sogar angeguckt
Es ist einer der am meisten verbundenen Gebäude der Erde.
Im Fakt, wenn du dieses Video hier aus dem Video siehst,
dann gehst du wahrscheinlich durch dieses Gebäude gerade jetzt.
Also, lass uns versuchen, da reinzukommen.
Wir werden dich, wenn du bereit bist.
beim rausgehen ich habe nie offiziell gehört was der hintergedanke dabei ist aber ich persönlich
denke mir das liegt daran dass du nichts rein bringst und drin lässt na ja ich glaube so genau
auf usb stick größe wird das nicht gehen was ist wenn man pinkel geht ich gehe mal davon aus dass
dass das nicht auf ein paar hundert Gramm
geht, ja.
Übrigens, ich hab da drin
überhaupt kein Klo gesehen. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob da drin ein Klo ist.
Keine Ahnung.
Also,
kein Schimmer,
ob man da überhaupt aufs Klo gehen kann.
... Play inside a datacenter today.
It's gonna be kinda crazy.
Look at all these timestamps.
We covered a lot.
Massive timestamps.
Yeah, go on into the InfoMars.
Now getting inside a datacenter is...
Okay, Chad.
Es gibt die Möglichkeit,
man geht kurz raus, die Treppe hoch und da aufs Klo.
Zweite Möglichkeit ist,
dann halt in die Ecke kacken.
Obviously, natürlich,
das Rausgehen und Treppe hochlaufen ist keine Option.
Man muss logischerweise in die Ecke kacken.
Okay, Sicherheitszeug musste ich nicht anziehen.
Man durfte da ohne Helm rein.
Nee, hat er auch kein Handy.
Bei Equinix war ich auch schon mal in Frankfurt.
Das hat er gut aufgesagt.
Ich glaube, eine Karte haben wir dort auch gekriegt zum Zugang.
Ich weiß das gar nicht mehr genau.
Das ist schon ein bisschen her, wo ich da war.
Karte und dann musst du es in so ein rundes Ding, wo du gewogen wurdest.
Ja.
Okay, da wirst du nicht gewohnt.
Moment, das ist ein Datacenter mit...
Mit Sessel? Nice.
Ja gut, das ist normal.
Lars sagt, im Oktober werde ich das erste Mal
in einer Zeit betreten, ich freue mich drauf.
Ja, nice.
Ich hätte auch wieder Bock,
ehrlich gesagt, mal öfters in einem Rechenzentrum
zu sein.
Während meiner Ausbildung war ich jeden Tag
mehrfach im Rechenzentrum, danach
auch noch eine ganze Zeit. Das wurde dann
aber über die Jahre immer weniger, immer weniger.
Bis zu jetzt beim neuen
Arbeitgeber, wo ich mit Ach und Krach weiß, an welchem
Standort die Rechenzentren sind.
Ich hätte auch mal wieder Bock.
Wisst ihr, was ich gerne machen würde?
Gibt es Rechenzentrum in NRW?
Mit Sicherheit, es gibt überall Rechenzentren.
Wisst ihr, was ich so richtig gerne mal machen würde? Das ist vielleicht jetzt sowas, was die meisten Leute, die es noch nicht gemacht haben, nicht verstehen können, aber ich würde gerne mal ein altes, fettes Playcenter einbauen wieder.
so richtig
oldschool ohne Akkuschrauber
oder elektronischen Hebedings
oder sowas, sondern einfach
mit zwei Leuten ins Rechenzentrum
und dann unter
Strapazen,
die halt Opa Max
erzählt vom Krieg, ist das richtig, ja,
dann unter Strapazen wieder erstmal
die Schienen reinbauen,
dann das Playcenter irgendwie da reinhängen,
dann gucken, dass sich nichts
verkantet, dann einbauen, dann
anschließen, dann vielleicht auch ein paar
Glasfaserkabel patchen oben
und zum Schrank und
ja, da hätte ich mal wieder Bock drauf.
Ich würde das sogar umsonst machen, wenn es mich
einer machen lässt. Aber da gibt es ja immer
die Leute, die sowas haben, die haben auch Leute
dafür, ja.
Du hast einfach Nostalgie für, ja gut,
das ist wie bei vielen Sachen.
Warum spielen die Leute World of Warcraft
Classic?
Weil es ein gutes Game ist.
Aber auch wegen Nostalgie.
Habt ihr das Drama
um die ganzen World of Warcraft Private Server
mitgekriegt.
Ich lass mich also nicht sidetracken,
sonst wären wir mit dem Video nicht fertig.
Blizzard hat
fast alle größeren Private World of Warcraft
Classic Server verklagt.
Und
einen nicht nur auf
Urheberrecht, also da hab ich das gelesen,
sondern auf
Bilden einer kriminellen Vereinigung oder sowas.
Also da haben sie alle Register gezogen.
Ja.
Wobei da vielleicht auch das ein oder andere
Zwielichtige abgelaufen ist, man weiß es ja nicht.
Also es geht um Turtle, Turtle Wow.
Ihr könnt ja mal nach den
News googeln, da ist
auch hinter den Kulissen wahrscheinlich ganz
viel grobes Zeug noch gelaufen, man weiß
es aber nicht wirklich, ob das so ist, ja.
Zumindest
bei denen ist das so,
die
Betreiberin
sitzt in Russland,
die
Firma dahinter
irgendwie
entweder auch in Russland
oder in Kasachstan
und die Server stehen auch entweder in Russland
oder Kasachstan. Also da wird Blizzard
wahrscheinlich nicht allzu viel machen können.
Aber
in dem Team sind ja noch mehr, außer die
Leute, die in Russland sitzen. Gibt ja auch noch welche, die
in der EU sitzen, welche in den USA sitzen,
auf die werden sie es wohl abgesehen haben.
Ja, also
da geht es zur Zeit ab, was
World of Warcraft und Private Server angeht.
War das abzusehen
oder war das Grauzone?
Naja, wie gesagt,
okay, das muss ich jetzt kurz einwerfen,
bevor wir das Video weitergucken.
Ich bin ja jetzt hier kein Rechtsexperte oder sowas,
dementsprechend kann ich da jetzt nicht wirklich
großartig mit Erfahrung
sprechen. Aber aus meiner Sicht ist es so, dass private Server erstmal prinzipiell keine
Urheberrechtsverletzung begehen, solange sie nicht Content verwenden, der vom Hersteller
kommt. Und es ist nicht zwingend notwendig dafür, dass du für einen privaten Server
Content vom Hersteller verwendest.
Der Client
kommt vom Hersteller.
Das ist ja nicht so, dass die Leute jetzt irgendwie
den Client da distributen
würden oder so.
Wobei, das machen sie teilweise auch. Das ist dann
problematisch. Aber rein die Server-Seite
kannst du nachbauen.
Und wenn du nicht irgendwie
geklauten Code hast,
oder Quest-Texte kopierst,
oder irgendwie Content
benutzt, der vom
eigentlichen Hersteller kommt, ist das
Programmieren und Betreiben
eines privaten Servers
für ein MMO aus meiner Sicht
nicht irgendwie urheberrechts
problematisch.
Wie kann ich einen privaten
World of Warcraft Server ohne Content
von Blizzard betreiben?
Na gut, du könntest ja den Content selbst erstellen.
Also man muss ja auch
die Serverseite muss ja auch unterscheiden
zwischen der Server
Software an sich, also quasi
das, was die Protokolle hinter
World of Warcraft implementiert
und dem, was da für einen
Inhalt anbietet, also irgendwelche Raids
oder Quests
oder Zonen oder
NPCs und alles mögliche.
Also rein das Programmieren
von einem Server,
der das
World of Warcraft Protokoll redet, wo man
sich quasi einloggen kann mit dem Client
und einen Charakter
erstellen kann und sowas.
Das ist nicht
aus meiner Sicht, glaube ich,
unüberrechtlich gar nicht so das große Problem.
Problematisch wird es, wenn du halt anfängst,
ähm,
bestehende Sachen halt zu kopieren.
Ja.
Ja, genau, wenn du alles selbst machst,
dann glaube ich nicht, dass das ein Problem ist.
Die Sache ist die, die Frage ist,
ob du es als World of Warcraft bewerben
darfst oder benennen darfst.
Das ist natürlich vom Namen her wieder problematisch.
Das weiß ich nicht.
Aber rein mal das Programmieren
von einem World of Warcraft Server
mit dem du dich beispielsweise mit einem älteren World of Warcraft-Client dagegen connecten kannst,
das ist kein, das denke ich nicht, dass das urheberrechtlich ein Problem ist.
Da verwendest du ja nichts von Blizzard.
Du quasi reimplementierst einfach das, was du mitgeschnitten hast oder so.
So sind ja diese ganzen Clients auch entstanden.
Die Leute haben das Spiel gestartet, haben mitgesnifft, was macht das Game
oder was erwartet das Game als Antworten und haben das nachgebaut.
Das ist ja kein Problem.
Ab wann ist es noch World of Warcraft?
Du wirst den World of Warcraft Client wahrscheinlich immer verwenden,
aber ohne die Server-Sighting-Inhalte ist es ja eigentlich ein eigenes Spiel.
Also du würdest dann den World of Warcraft Client verwenden
und deinen komplett eigenen Inhalt, dann wäre das kein Problem.
Sobald du aber, wie gesagt, sobald du das machst,
wie es die ganzen Private Server gemacht haben,
quasi mit offiziellen Quests, die es auch in Retail oder damals in Classic gab,
Das ist dann kein, das ist keine Frage. Das ist auf jeden Fall Urheberrechtsproblematisch, ja. Sobald da Questtexte kopiert werden, NPC-Namen, NPCs oder halt irgendwelche anderen Sachen, die eindeutig sich ein anderer ausgedacht hat, ja.
Das ist Grauzone. Aber wie gesagt, das eigentliche Nachimplementieren und Nachbauen eines World of Warcraft Servers, da bin ich mir eigentlich relativ sicher, das ist rechtlich Copyright-technisch kein Problem. Der Inhalt und die Assets und das Copyright-geschützte Material ist es. Aber rein das Reimplementieren der Protokolle ist kein Problem.
Es gibt ja beispielsweise auch, beim EverQuest gibt es auch jede Menge private Server oder Dark Edge of Camelot, mein absolutes Lieblings-MMO, gibt es auch einen großen Private Server und dort ist es halt auch so gut, da steckt jetzt keine so große Firma mehr dahinter wie Microsoft, Blizzard, wobei ich gar nicht weiß, ob die nicht noch irgendwie zu EA gehören, aber die kriegen es ja selbst schon nicht hin, ihren Kram zu betreiben bei Dark Edge of Camelot.
und da ist es halt auch so,
die verwenden den offiziellen Client,
du darfst den offiziellen Client auch nicht bei denen runterladen,
sondern du musst dir den offiziellen Client vom Hersteller ziehen
und dann connectest du dich halt mit diesem Client
gegen den privaten Server,
wo die quasi das Dark Age of Camelot Protokoll neu implementiert haben
und ja, da ist es jetzt halt so ein bisschen Grauzone,
die haben halt fast alles übernommen
von
aus
also vieles aus dem Game übernommen
an Mechaniken und alles
ja da kann man sich jetzt drüber schreiten
das ist sicherlich Grauzone
was da
ob das erlaubt ist oder nicht
aber Dark Age of Camelot ist so krass Nische
und letztendlich interessiert es auch keinen so richtig
dass das Spiel ja noch live ist, es ist ja nicht wie
World of Warcraft, wo denen da teilweise Millionen durch die Lappen gehen
da interessiert sich glücklicherweise
keiner für
Zumal man ja sagen muss,
Dark Eden
ist viel, viel besser als
Retail und kriegen
das viel besser hin als der offizielle Betreiber
des Spiels. So, aber
da wollte ich mich jetzt gar nicht so sehr sidetracken lassen.
Wir gucken jetzt das Video weiter.
Es gab keine Source Code Leaks vom World of Warcraft Server.
Die haben das echt komplett neu gebaut. Meines Wissens
auch schon, ja.
Meines Wissens ist das so.
Wenn Blizzard mit einer fetten Klage kommt, dann wird man den Server einstellen.
Ja, machen die meisten ja auch aktuell.
Die meisten privaten World of Warcraft Server machen zur Zeit dicht.
Turtle Wow macht nicht dicht, weil, wie gesagt, die Betreiberin sitzt in Russland.
Der Server steht, glaube ich, irgendwie in Kasachstan.
und die machen zur Zeit eher, fahren die Schiene,
wir sind quasi so der Underdog, der sich gegen Blizzard stellt.
Und die haben damit aktuell auch sehr viel Zulauf.
Man darf aber nicht vergessen,
die machen das sicherlich auch nicht nur aus reiner Nächstenliebe,
sondern die haben ja auch einen Ingame-Shop.
Also sie machen das auch, um Geld zu verdienen.
viele privaten, gerade World of Warcraft
private Serverbetreiber machen das, um Geld zu verdienen
bei Dark Age of Camelot ist es
was anderes, die nehmen explizit
kein Geld an, keine Donations
an
ja
aber WoW-Server
wollen ja sogar Geld damit verdienen, das heißt also
die machen das nicht nur aus reiner
Nächstenliebe
es gab einen Leak, die
privaten, das weiß ich nicht, also ich hab gedacht, die haben
das alles nachgebaut
So, jetzt gucken wir aber das Video.
Uns wird das überhaupt nichts.
Ich habe jetzt wieder 20 Minuten Zeit getrackt.
Aber warum die extra Tür? Wir haben sie bereits authentiziert, oder?
Ja, aber es gibt Läufer.
Du siehst, als Kunde in diesem Datacenter,
hast du nur den Zugang zu deiner Sachen.
Der Boden, an dem deine Sachen sind, und die Kuh, in der deine Sachen leben.
Ja, es gibt eine andere Fläche, die einen anderen Tuch und eine andere Fingerprint benötigt.
Das ist verrückt.
Aber dann sahen wir das, als wir durch diese Türen gegangen sind.
Ich sah...
einen Fingerscanner
und da musstest du mit einem Finger
konntest entsperren, mit dem anderen Finger konntest du wieder sperren.
Und ein Kollege von mir,
der hatte irgendwie so einen, weiß ich nicht,
merkwürdigen Finger,
dass da regelmäßig die Alarmanlage
ausgelöst hat.
Wenn er da mit seinem Finger gescannt hat.
Die geilste Story ist ja eh noch,
Das wurde damals, also das eines der Rechenzentren in Frankfurt, die wir damals, wo ich noch
beim Provider gearbeitet habe, in Frankfurt betrieben haben, war für eine Bank.
Und dort war das so, dass der Alarm, der wurde still ausgelöst und kam bei der Polizei raus.
Das heißt, wenn da irgendwas war in der Richtung, hast du es nicht mitgekriegt und auf einmal
hat es das Sondereinsatzkommando im Rechenzentrum stehen.
Das ist jetzt nicht übertrieben.
Also das war alles nicht so...
nicht bis ins letzte Detail durchdacht.
Also ich weiß so, dass die Alarmanlage öfters ausgelöst hat
bei meinem Kollegen mit dem komischen Finger.
Moment, ist das das
bestplatzierte Placement ever?
Also wenn das
ein Placement war, war das richtig
eine indikation auf what company die servers belong to mess by design
das walking past ist der gute steht da ohne dran racks if you happen to notice
a company you're familiar with and seeing what servers and networking
hardware they use those and trade secrets and then equinix
takes it a step further notice the lights in this place
They're blue.
Also eins hat mich ein bisschen so disillusioniert.
Ich dachte früher immer,
so Pairing ist sowas voll,
sowas voll, es war für mich immer sowas abstraktes,
wenn es um Peering ist, das ist nicht Pairing, ne, Peering.
Wenn es um Peering bei Provider ging, da hab ich immer gedacht,
boah ey, das ist ja voll irgendwie High IQ Netzwerkzeug.
und als ich dann selbst gesehen habe, war das halt ziemlich
zwei Glasfaserkabel von einem Switch
an den anderen, so.
Das war viel weniger spektakulär,
als ich mir das vorgestellt habe.
Also ich habe damals unser Peering
zu Freenet selbst gesteckt in Frankfurt, ja.
An den Switch.
Wobei es wahrscheinlich eher,
Wenn ich mir das so recht überlege, war es wahrscheinlich eher ein Router, kein Switch.
Aber es war was mit vielen Netzwerk-Ports.
Wahrscheinlich irgendein Kombi-Ding.
Warum springt er beim Reden eigentlich die ganze Zeit so rum?
Also, dazu muss ich sagen, ja,
ich hab mich da dran auch schon geschnitten
beziehungsweise Finger eingeklemmt
aber ich hab gehört
heute ist das so
dass man
die Server nicht mehr selbst heben muss
und auch nicht mehr selbst schrauben muss
also mit dem Schraubendreher
ich hab von unseren Azubis gehört
die haben eine elektronische
Hebevorrichtung für Server
und einen Akkuschrauber
sowas gab es bei uns
nicht Leute
Wo hab ich mein Rentner-Emote?
Hab ich kein
Opa Max?
Hab ich kein Opa Max-Emote?
Was ist das? Ich hab kein Rentner-Emote
Oder bin ich zu blind, das zu sehen?
Egal
Muss ich mir vorstellen
fast wie ein Gabelstapler nur in klein...
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das Ding aussieht.
Ja?
Wir mussten die Dinger noch selbst reinheben,
noch selbst festschrauben,
die, die, diese
Muttern da irgendwie reinmachen,
reinklipsen.
Das sind ja, die sind ja teilweise auch
richtig eklig. Die haben ja solche kleinen
Zähnchen drin, ne? Diese...
Nein.
Die da meine ich.
Ne, die meine ich nicht.
Die hier.
Die hier meine ich, ja.
Die haben ja so kleine Zähnchen drin.
Die musst du so leicht zusammendrücken.
Dann kannst du die reinmachen.
Und dann gehen die wieder ein bisschen auseinander.
Wobei, sind die das überhaupt?
Ja, doch.
Hier sieht man es neben, ne?
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob das die richtigen...
Das sind nicht die richtigen.
Hier, die da.
Hier sieht man genau die, meine ich.
Guck, hier, da sieht man
doch die Häkchen.
Massive Fire.
Die hier, guck.
Hier sieht man diese Zähnchen.
Die drückst du hier unten dran,
dann gehen die ein bisschen zusammen,
dann schiebst du die quasi ins Rack, lässt los
und dann beißen die sich da so rein.
Aber wir hatten früher nur die hier.
Und durch das
Festschrauben drücken die sich da nochmal
besonders rein.
da drin. Und die sind schon
bombenfest.
Also ich hab mir da auch schon den Finger geschnitten.
Oder noch besser,
ich auch schon geschafft hab,
unter den Fingernagel
mir so ein Ding zu stecken.
Wenn du sowas den ganzen Tag gebaut hast,
oder halben Tag,
dann hast du schon echt
gemerkt.
Ja Leute,
zu Opa Max Zeiten
war das noch harte arbeit selber einzubauen
doch weiter
da gibt es jetzt besseres ich habe lange nichts eingebaut im rechten zentrum ich weiß nur es
Es gibt mittlerweile so welche aus Plastik.
Weiß nicht, wie verbreitet die sind.
Aber das fand ich vom Ansatz her eigentlich ganz cool.
Ihr habt doch ganz sicher die Verletzung auf diesem Verletzungszettel.
Ne.
Weißt, dass du so meinst, dass ich jetzt sage, haben wir nicht.
Aber ne, haben wir nicht.
Hätte ich da jetzt keine Ahnung, Titanus gekriegt oder so und wäre im Krankenhaus gelandet,
wäre es kein Arbeitsunfall gewesen, weil ich die Verletzung nicht reingetragen habe.
Aber zum Glück sind die Dinger ja sauber.
Ich muss mal kurz meine Abendpillen nehmen.
Warte mal.
Das sehe ich bestimmt nicht gerne.
So if you want to get tackled by someone.
Noted.
But other cages, they actually have a closed top.
And some I couldn't even see.
They were in enclosed areas.
Some customers are also not additionally just to the deck there.
They actually put the mesh underneath that as well.
And it's fully enclosed.
Top secret.
I wasn't allowed in there.
Still bummed about that.
I would imagine there are some crazy top secret companies in this data center.
There's gotta be.
And it's kind of cool.
If you need top secret stuff, Equinix will give you what you need.
Customers can also...
Das ist gar nicht gesponsert von denen.
... aber es ist ja auch nicht schlimm. Ich meine, das muss ich ja für alle Seiten lohnen.
... hier, ich werde hier schlagen, es wird mich negieren, weil ich nicht der Kostüm von dieser Kage bin.
Jetzt, sprichst du von Sicherheit, was ist mit den Leuten?
Wie die Leute, die dort arbeiten. Ich habe tatsächlich gelernt, dass es kein Lüge ist, ein Equinix-Techniker zu werden.
Das ist Manny. Er hat als Techniker vor 20 Jahren angefangen.
Ich bin mit Equinix seit 24 Jahren zusammengearbeitet.
Ich bin seit 25 Jahren im Juli dabei.
Ich bin Verkaufsingenieur.
Ich habe als Techniker angefangen seit 8 Jahren.
Hier im Datacenter DA1.
Ich war Verkaufsingenieur.
Ich war 8 Jahre Verkaufsingenieur.
Das sind die 24 Jahre zusammen.
Und das ist Teil ihres Interviewprozesses.
Sie haben mich zu diesem anderen Gebäude genommen.
Und sie hatten einen Rack, wo man einen Test durchführen musste.
Oh, wirklich? Wollten die von dir das Kabel krimpen?
Ey, ein CCNA habe ich auch, ja?
Nicht, dass ich noch irgendwas von könnte.
Leute, wisst ihr, was das Einzige ist, was ich mir von CCNA gemerkt habe?
dass man EN tippen muss am Anfang
und dass man
wie war das?
Save Running Start
oder irgendwie so
machen musste
zum Speichern
Copy Running Start
ja genau
No Shutdown
zum Port hochfahren
ja das weiß ich auch noch was ist ccna cisco certified network associate kann das sein das
ist von cisco so zertifikat was du machen kannst dass du dich so basic mäßig netzwerk mäßig aus
kennst
aber damals sogar gewusst wie man uspf aufs disco geräten konfiguriert wird
heute im leben da mal hinkriegen
wie langsamer 3 wie langsamer glaube ich relativ simpel auf jeden fall waren die
wir waren wie langsamer als bei mikro tic was ich bei mir hier privat verwende
WLANs waren relativ easy.
Ich weiß nur, dass Cisco,
Cisco haben das irgendwie
Trunk-Port genannt.
Und das ist irgendwie so ein Spezial-Cisco-Wort
für einen Port, wo mehrere WLANs drüber erlaubt sind.
Also quasi wo, ähm,
also von Switch zu Switch.
Oder halt wo getaggte Pakete
reingehen dürfen im Endeffekt.
trunkport hieß das glaube ich
bei getagten Ports ist es ja so
dass der WLAN Tag wird ja quasi
entfernt
beim aus dem Port rausgehen
reingehen
also beim rausgehen
trunkports haben
die Pakete auf Layer 2 können
WLAN Tags stehen haben
trunk mit T
Bis die Meilen zu erhoben, keine Ahnung, hab ich nie benutzt.
Ich hätte es eigentlich gedacht, dass das doppelter Boden ist.
Ja, hätte ich gedacht.
Sie pumpen eigentlich kühle Luft aus dem Boden ein, weil ihr wisst, dass heißes Luft aufsteigt.
Dieses Land hatte das nicht.
Wie kühlen sie das?
Na gut, wahrscheinlich kühlen die pro Würfel, sagen wir mal.
Wobei, die Server standen ja nicht in irgendwelchen eigenen...
Die Racks standen ja nicht in irgendwelchen eigenen Abgrenzungen.
Also, ja, keine gute Frage, wie die das mit dem Kühlen machen.
Diese Facility, wir haben auch Luft von der Seite gedrückt.
Na ja, weil, guck, die sind, die stehen einfach, die Racks...
Die kühlen das Ganze.
Die Racks stehen einfach nur so da.
Was ich schon gesehen habe ist, dass die Racks halt in so Würfeln drin stehen, quasi so
so eigenen Container nochmal, wo das dann mit der Kühlung gemacht wird.
Wo man dann quasi eine Seite hat, wo Luft angesaugt wird, meistens außen und dann innen
drin in so einen Gang rein.
Äh ne, doch genau.
und die Hot Air ist eigentlich über und über durch Ventilation gedrückt, also typische Hot Air
Riesensituation.
Ich frage Sal, welches besser ist, die gestellte Flur oder die Art, wie sie es tun, die Luft aus der Seite zu drücken.
We can argue to work and blue of those lights.
It's just a preference when it's all said and done.
They use slab floors because it can hold more weight.
Those server racks are heavy.
Now on every floor they have air handlers at the end of the hall that cool everything.
But the power of this is on the roof.
And the way they cool this data center is kind of like a gaming computer.
Hear me out. It's like liquid cooling.
On the top you have your radiator, like your gaming PC.
You normally mount your radiator and the fans to the top.
You'll have your water or your liquid go to your radiator, get cooled off by the fans
and they get pushed back down to your GPU or your CPU.
Ich mache mal weiter.
der in die cloud die also mal herz und stuff backen der data center in der hybrid cloud situation so
that connection du die can't be crappy but often it kind of it's we're usually connecting through
the cloud ist auch so ein bisschen besser aktuell big bad wild internet hopping between routers
connections with potentially bad latency and frequent drops es kann auch nicht going on a
road trip you can't guarantee the quality of the roads you don't control any of that and you never
know when there's gonna be traffic that's the internet das war die just los und da ist bei
aqua nix they flip the script on this they help people skip the internet es ist so well connected
Das ist das am besten verbundenste Gebäude der Erde.
Ja Max, ich finde das auch ein bisschen hektisch, aber das gucken wir mal fertig.
Und wir sprechen über zwei Gebäude, nicht nur eines.
Das Haupt-Datacenter ist das DA11.
Es ist flasch, es ist frisch, es ist bereit, all eure verrückten AI-Modelle zu hosten.
So wirklich viel gesehen hat man jetzt ja nicht, oder?
Auf der Straße ist etwas etwas älter.
Das ist das Infomarkt, das am besten verbundenste Datacenter im Südwesten.
Los geht's.
Das ist das DA1, das Infomarkt.
Es ist ziemlich schön, aber es hat das retro-futuristische,
Das ist ja mal richtig hoch, ey.
Also wenn ich auf was gehypt bin, dann eher auf das neue Battlefield.
Aber ich bin auf beides nicht sonderlich gehypt.
Was sieht man denn so wirklich in einem Datasender?
Zum Beispiel hätte mich die ganze Netzwerksache mal interessiert.
Wie das ausschaut.
Man könnte auch mal wirklich so die Server zeigen von hinten, wie die Racks so aufgebaut sind, weil das ja jeder Customer ein bisschen anders macht.
Also haben wir schon viel interessantere.
Also beispielsweise das Video vom Bauer bei Hetzner war viel besser.
Das war aber schon vor der Zeit und es hat sich nicht geändert.
Jetzt sind wir von diesem großen, großen,
von einem jungen...
Aber zurück in unsere Käse.
Hier befindet sich etwas, was ich als coolste Idee je gedacht habe.
Es heißt Fabrik.
Nokia!
MonkaS, Alter!
Statt 1 Mio. Cross-Connections zu allen Firmen zu bekommen,
gibt es nur eine Verbindung.
Das ist Equinix Fabrik.
Das ist etwas, das wir vor 10 Jahren designt haben.
Wir wurden mit Internet Exchange oder IX gegründet.
Das ist so, wie wir angefangen haben, wo Leute literally Cross-Connect machen würden, also eine 1-zu-1-Verkaufsverkauf, wo sie von einem Kunden zu einem anderen Kunden verbinden und dann hätten wir alle zusammen, wie in einem Datenzentrum, also wären sie in nahem Proximit.
Also haben wir die Fabrik entwickelt, so dass man jetzt nur das eine Board bekommt und man kann mehrere virtuelle Verbindungen erzeugen.
dabei aber jetzt habe jetzt irgendwie gedacht da sieht man ein bisschen mehr
aber nicht hier next
und ansonsten noch der hype ums rennen radeln von sportler zu rasen war der titel schon zehn
cli apps that have actually improved the way i work in the terminal
solche videos sind immer ziemlich hit und hit oder miss
wir machen das mal wir machen das war im schnelldurchlauf mal gucken was für krasse
terminal tools wir gezeigt kriegen okay das erste gibt's wird es bei mir machen das anders
wir wir wir out outplayen youtube wir gucken uns einfach die captions an
das war's also oxide brahmanet das ist irgendwie so eine cd replacement glaube
ich
rg ist eine alternative die ich nicht verwende
sag auch gleich warum weil ich denke dass die gleiche erklärung noch für mehr
passt fd ist der alternative zu feind
Verwende ich auch nicht.
Alles written in Rust, ja.
Tmux, Tmux beste.
Ich verwende Tmux mittlerweile
nicht mal so oft wie früher.
Liegt daran,
da ich ein Terminal verwende,
was Native Splits und Zooms und Tabs und so kann.
Das ist, by the way, hier unten,
das ist kein Tmux, das ist mein Terminal.
auf dem server verwende ich das jeden tag mehrfach thema das beste github brauche ich nicht doppler
doppler ist irgend so eine secret management lösung für kuba net ist keine an dass irgendwie
kein top sie alle app pass in passwort manager ok mark nice sein habe ich nicht verwendet jq
JQ ist richtig gut.
Das ist Westterm, ja.
Wegen der Sessions, was meinst du?
Du meinst, warum ich das auf Servern verwende?
Ja, wegen der Sessions.
Wir haben beispielsweise jetzt, ich habe am Freitag
erst gemietet.
Da meinte einer,
wir haben euch ein paar
SQL-Skripte geschickt.
Könntet ihr die mal da und da ausführen?
Aber, Achtung!
In Produktion kann das bis zu 4 Wochen laufen.
vier wochen und ob wir das nicht irgendwo schedule wollen damit es nicht abbricht habe ich auch
gesagt leute kein problem connecten sie uns auf die kiste machen eine thema session auf und solange
den server keiner restartet passiert nichts aber vier wochen alle nutzer eigentlich auch
vor allem bei Workstation seit Prodcom das free gemacht hat.
Ja, mach ich hier.
Vor allem bei Workstation.
Und mein Terminal ist Westterm, ja.
Loon.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Die waren super optimiert, ja.
Ich hab da zig Schleifen
und sonst was drin gesehen.
Und es hieß,
es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten. Entweder
wir lassen das wo laufen, wo es nicht abbrechen kann
oder wir sollen
von Hand das SQL-Skript editieren
und immer die
den Schleifendurchlauf
Nummern anpassen,
sodass er quasi beim ersten Durchlauf 0 bis
100 macht, beim zweiten Durchlauf
101 bis 200, beim dritten Durchlauf
und sagt, ne ne, wir starten
das in der T-Mark Session.
Ich will da nichts editieren.
NoHub geht sicherlich auch, aber
Temux ist die bessere Variante.
Vor allem bei Temux ist das Schöne,
dass du
auch andere Leute
da drauf gucken lassen kannst.
Oder mit anderen zusammen.
Also ich wollte es hier noch lesen.
Danke für die ganze Motivation über die Jahre.
Habe 2021, oder bis jetzt sogar schon
relativ spät dabei, deinen Kanal
gefunden und fand dann IT interessant.
Hatte auch einen Werkstudentenjob
im Studium in der Branche, nachdem
ich damals schon zu krone aufgegeben habe habe ich dann eine ausbildung angefangen so viel spannendes
viel davon obzeugt gelernt und werde vom ausbildungsbetrieb zu guten konditionen übernommen
das ist sehr nice ich hoffe du hast gutes erstes gehalt ausgehandelt aktuell hat man es ja ganz
gut als it specialists das ist aber das freut mich immer zu lesen wenn mein dummes gespräch
spätze auch mal ab und zu hilft ja und thema ist wirklich beste da kann man so
sachen machen wie ich starte hier eine thema session übrigens kommt es mit
meinem terminal fahren nicht klar aber wurscht so dann log ich mich per ssh
beispielsweise irgendwo ein dann sage ich thema touch und bin auf der gleichen
session drauf als guck wenn ich hier schreibe dann ist es hups dann ist es
dann ist es hier da so wenn ich hier schreibe dann ist es hier auch das also es geht auch
über ssh mit mehreren personen wir benutzen das auf der arbeit sogar relativ oft dass ich mich
ich mich verbinde auf dem server und andere sich verbindet auf dem server und dann sagen wir hier
machen wir eine thema session auf und dann verbinden wir uns auf die jeweilig andere
thema session wir sind ja beide wir dürfen ja beide root werden da startet man einfach als
routetemuxsession und
connectet sich dazu und dann kann man zusammen tippen
und zusammen gucken, ohne dass man
irgendwie Teamscreensharing oder so ein Müll braucht.
Das ist aber nicht viel.
Mal zwölf oder mal vierzehn?
Da geht auf jeden Fall noch was nach oben.
So viel kann ich dazu sagen.
Ach, so viel gutes Einstiegsgehalt.
Ich hab ja gesagt, das ist ja fast schon Mindestlohn.
ich wollte ich wollte jetzt nicht so drastisch aus weil sich schlecht reden
wollte und dann jemand denkt so an jetzt habe ich immer schlechter
weil jetzt wo ich sehe dass du linux und windows wird hast du schon was von win
was wind baut nicht kenne ich was das wind baut windows apps und linux ist ach
ja doch habe ich habe ich habe ich ein video letzten zu gesehen ja das ist mir
per rdp geht das dann da hast du eine vm mit windows wo die sache drin laufen und
per quasi headless rdp wird das übertragen eine coole idee
gut oder der haube ist es kvm windows läuft er nicht in docker sind kvm was
in Docker läuft, was dann Windows ausführt.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch hier
Schönes?
CLI Apps.
JQ. Also JQ ist
auf jeden Fall bester. JQ verwende ich auch
laufend. Ehrlich gesagt,
am häufigsten verwende ich gar nicht die
krassen Features von JQ,
sondern eigentlich nur, um
JSON-Output ordentlich zu formatieren
im Terminal.
So diese ganzen Sachen, die man damit machen kann,
sich einzelne Elemente rausholen und sonst
was mache ich sehr selten. Aber
ein Curl gepiped nach
JQ mache ich sehr oft.
Einfach um JSON-Output ordentlich zu formatieren.
Aber JQ ist das Beste. Ist wirklich super.
Stow. Gut.
Ob man jetzt Dot-File-Manager braucht
oder nicht, kann man sich streiten.
FZF. FZF ist auch gut.
FZF ist richtig nice.
Ist ein Fuzzy-Finder fürs Terminal.
Da kann man zum Beispiel sowas hier machen, wie
LS, LA
nach FZF pipen.
Und dann kann ich jetzt hier drinnen suchen.
Guck hier, Deno zum Beispiel. Zack.
Oder Garmin.
Oder ich kann sogar Armen
suchen und da finde ich Garmin.
FZF ist wirklich
Pog.
Ja, und
ich habe ja gesagt, hier manche Sachen
verwende ich nicht. Beispielsweise
ich verwende keine Grepp-Alternative, keine
feind alternative und auch keine cd alternative das liegt daran dass es da
relativ gute standard tools gibt und wenn ich anfange alternativ tools zu
verwenden dann verlern ich die standard benutzung von feind und von grepp und
Nachdem auf den Servern, auf denen ich täglich unterwegs bin, weder RG, also RIP-GREP ist das, noch FD installiert ist, bringt mir das Ganze nichts.
Ich muss das schon aus dem FF hinkriegen, wie man ordentlich greppt und wie man ordentlich fein verwendet.
Deswegen verwende ich das bei mir auch nicht.
Deswegen bin ich ja auch wieder umgestiegen von einer super langen, customizierten WIM-Config mit 3000 Plugins zu einer WIM-Config, die äußerst übersichtlich ist.
einfach weil ich die standard bedienung nicht verlernen will
leon danke für den sub die sache nach gibt es doch nicht mal die ganzen sachen
gibt es noch nicht mal in red hat package oder ubuntu packages sage ich
jetzt einfach ohne nachgeguckt zu haben
oder soll ich erst mal irgendwie mich ins internet tunnel von unseren servern
damit ich dann AW getten kann.
Oder auf meine Kiste W getten und überall hin CPen.
Mag sein.
Ich habe bisher noch nicht irgendwie das Verlangen danach verspürt.
Vielleicht hat es tatsächlich große Vorteile,
die man erst merkt, wenn man es verwendet.
Ja, richtig, sehe ich genauso.
wenn man natürlich jetzt hauptsächlich bei sich unterwegs ist auf seiner vm
wenn man bei mann ein paar bein genommen ist entwickler und ist eigentlich nur
auf seiner kiste unterwegs dann kann man sich die wirklich komplett
customizen wie man es gerne hätte also dann auch alle möglichen zusatzsachen
installieren und sonst was so spricht ja nichts dagegen
aber ich der halt auf vielen systemen unterwegs ist und sie auch mit
standardtools auskennen muss ist es blöd wenn ich da jetzt mit irgendwelchen
Ersatzdingern anfangen.
So.
Also haben wir durch. Easy, oder?
Haben wir das Video
geskippt?
Was haben wir denn hier noch?
11 New CSS Features.
Jeder Browser
unterstützt in 2005.
Leute, CSS Features.
Ich habe leider kein
keck W CSS. Ich habe nur ein keck W
JavaScript da.
also mein job aktuell also in meinem arbeitsvertrag steht dass ich senior
linux engineer bin klingt aber viel geiler vom titel her oder viel wichtiger
als es ist vom titel her
ok wisst ihr was frontend stelle oder was haben wir sonst noch was ist das
wlan für event mit 2500 usern aber nur sieben tagen zeit und steinzeit dsl wie
geht das okay
hype us rennen
chat was was was wollen wir gucken wir haben zur auswahl css features
hype ums rennen radeln windows 10 ende so einfach geht es zu linux oder wlan
event für 2500 user aber nur sieben tage zeit und steinzeit dsl hype ums rennen
jetzt haben wir alles
ok wir haben zweimal wlan event zweimal halb ums rennen okay dann machen wir
das so dann gucken wir jetzt das was kürzer geht wlan okay die leute sagen
wir dann dann dann gucken wir uns mal schnell dass hier mit wlan an und
danach gucken uns das mit brennrad an wonka s was passiert hier
wann ist unify access points sah ein bisschen so aus oder
herzlich willkommen hier auf dem host unlimited youtube kanal ich freue mich
dass ihr wieder eingeschaltet habt und dieses mal hat es sich gelohnt denn wir
Wenn die Musik kommt, muss ich wieder gleich runterdrehen.
Okay, let's go.
Ein Vermittler von Rechenleistung, das ist auch eine geile Umschreibung.
auf den Kunden zugeschnitten. Aber egal, genug Werbegesülze. So und heute stehen wir hier an
der Eventhalle in Braunschweig, das MEC, das Millennium Event Center in Braunschweig. Einer
unserer Kunden, der ist selbst Trainer, Live Coach, Event Trainer, ziemlich bekannt, heißt Damian Richter.
Der hat zugestimmt, dass wir filmen dürfen, wofür wir hier beauftragt wurden. Und zwar ist hier quasi
der Auftrag gewesen, für diesen Kunden ein WiFi-Netz in den wichtigsten Bereichen aufzubauen, was man
auch wieder mitnehmen kann wenn man das möchte und was in der lage ist 2500 usern eine gute
stabile internetverbindung bereitzustellen weil der das sah echt aus wie unifax ist ihr wisst
euch kein großer fan von unifax bin aber ich gehe davon aus die wissen was sie machen und das will
auch funktionieren hat er uns beauftragten möchte dass nachher zum beispiel gewinnspiele und also
was während der veranstaltung gemacht werden und er steht auf der bühne und sagt hier ist nimmt
alle handy raus geht man auf unsere seite blub und da seht ihr dies und das und das muss natürlich
natürlich klappen, weil 2500 Leute vielleicht sogar noch mehr. Auf einmal ist eine ganz schöne Last für ein Netzwerk und da reicht halt ein normales Fritz-Box-Gerät nicht, um für 2500 Leute in so einer riesen Halle, die wir euch auch noch zeigen werden, das Internet bereit zu stellen.
Ist da so ein Comedy-Gruppe-Typ, für den er das macht? Keine Ahnung, was das für eine Veranstaltung ist.
Ich hab gedacht, wir kaufen einfach zwei Fritz-Boxen. Ganz einfach. Weil wenn eine Fritz-Box nicht reicht, dann nimmt man halt einfach zwei. Zwei Stück, die bauen wir da jetzt irgendwo ein und dann ist gut.
Der Cheebaitet jetzt, oder?
Wollen wir eigentlich schon fertig, oder?
Ja, wir sind fertig.
Nee, Spaß beiseite.
Es sagt sich mir, dass es Cheebait ist.
Also erstmal, wir hatten nur ganz wenig Zeit, weil hier sollte eigentlich eine Wifi-Anlage schon eingebaut werden.
Aber es gab da irgendwelche Komplikationen aufgrund von Lieferschwierigkeiten.
Das ist quasi gefloppt.
Und das zweite Problem ist, wir befinden uns hier auf einem alten Industriegelände.
Und früher war gar nicht, und das liegt auch ein bisschen abseits.
Und hier ist es ziemlich schwierig, eine schnelle Internetverbindung für 2500 Leute zu bekommen.
Glasfaser gibt es noch nicht. Wenn man Glasfaser
wollen würde oder bekommen wollen würde, wäre das
sehr teuer hier an diesem Standort. Und mit DSL
habe ich gesehen, gibt es hier irgendwie nur DSL 16.000.
Ist also auch keine gute Alternative.
Und da stand im Gespräch dann,
ja, was machen wir? Was können wir machen als Lösung,
um hier wirklich spontan innerhalb von
kürzester Zeit diese Interfverbindung aufzubauen?
Wir hatten gerade mal eine Woche Zeit. Stand eigentlich ja nur
zur Debatte 5G oder
Starlink. Ich habe mir gedacht, ist wahrscheinlich 5G die
bessere Alternative, weil der Kunde das halt immer nur über das
Wochenende braucht. Und da bucht er sich halt bei
seinen Anbietern dann am besten eine Fläche.
Kein Glasfaserkabel durch die Hecke gelegt, bis irgendwo hin.
So eine 24-Stunden-Flat für 5 Euro, unlimitiertes Datenvolumen.
Und genau das haben wir jetzt auch gemacht.
Und deswegen haben wir hier zwei Fritzboxen, weil wir uns tatsächlich gedacht haben, eine wird nicht reichen.
Jetzt haben wir hier zwei Stück.
Ach, die sind für 5G, die Fritzboxen?
Die haben wieder hier die besten Leistungen geliefert.
Aber 2500 Leute über 5G ist wahrscheinlich auch sportlich, hä?
Das ist keine Werbung.
Nach unserem Test, dass an diesem Standort hier die Telekom und Autour das beste Netz haben.
Wir haben sogar auch Vodafone ausprobiert.
ich habe die sim-karte hier sogar noch im auto vodafone hat aber leider versagt weil vodafone
obwohl sie eigentlich 5g geben sollte nur ganz selten mal so ein balken geliefert hat o2 und
telekom aber super wert ich zeige euch die werte nachher auch noch mal spitzenwerte die wir
erreicht hatten waren pro leitung 300 mbit das heißt 600 mbit könnten wir kombiniert in der
sache und die haben durch das recht ich hatte ja recht ist glück dass davon 5g gibt teilen und es
fragt euch wie macht ihr denn das ist ja eine riesen halle doch nicht mit diesen beiden dinger
dass ihr die einfach irgendwo aufstellt. Ich sage euch auch, also aus meiner Erfahrung,
so eine Fritzbox bricht ja auch zusammen, wenn da mehr als 40, 50 Geräte direkt drauf verbunden
sind über die Wifi-Module hier drin. Da kommt die einfach nicht hinterher und dementsprechend
haben wir natürlich auch eine professionelle Lösung geschafft, die der Kunde auch bequem
mitnehmen kann. Jetzt geht es aber weiter. Stellt euch vor, diese Fritzboxen werden hier
provisorisch im Außenbereich montiert. So und da unten seht ihr schon die Kisten,
Haben wir schon vorbereitet.
Sind Fritzboxen wasserdicht?
Da kommen die beiden Fritzboxen rein.
Ah, ah.
Ein Plastikbehälter ist für die Fritzbox.
Der Standort hier bietet super guten Empfang.
Der Bereich hier ist auch nicht zugänglich.
Das wird hier quasi abgesperrt.
Es gibt auch einen Sicherheitsdienst, der passt auf, dass die nicht abhanden kommt.
Normalerweise könnte man die ja noch super irgendwie aufs Dach positionieren
oder mit einer richtigen LTE-Antenne arbeiten,
die fest und statisch montiert wird mit dem besten Empfang, mit der besten Ausrichtung.
Aber wir sind einfach ums Gelände gelaufen, haben getestet, wo ist der beste Empfang.
Und die Ecke.
Hier hinter uns kann man vielleicht auch sehen,
das ist auch ein Berg. Wir waren sogar auf dem Berg drauf
und haben geguckt, wie da der Empfang ist,
haben aber festgestellt, dass die Antennen
alle aus der anderen Richtung strahlen
und dadurch war da oben auf dem Berg der Empfang nicht viel besser.
Also, ob man nun da
direkt, ne, oder da hinten auf dem Berg,
das hat nicht so viel Unterschied gemacht.
Und die 20 Mbit, dafür hätten wir hier aber 300 Meter
Kabel. Ich mag das, wenn so
improvisiert wird.
Kann nicht immer alles glatt gehen.
Und ich hab auch ein Herz für Bastelkram
verlegen müssen. Und das wäre mit einer Kupferleitung
auch gar nicht so leicht gegangen. Hätte man Repeater
gebraucht auf dem Kabelweg und und und
und. Haben wir also verworfen die Idee.
Die Dinger kommen da unten rein. Und jetzt brauchen wir noch
irgendwas, um das Wifi-Netz professionell
im Gebäude zu verteilen. Das zeige ich
euch jetzt, wie wir das machen. Und zwar haben wir hier
einen Wifi-Controller und gleichzeitig auch
einen Lautbalancer von Ubiquiti. Das ist die
Dream Machine Special Edition. Die ermöglicht
uns nachher hier die beiden Fritzboxen
anzuschließen an den Warnports.
Man kann zwei Geräte anschließen. Man kann sogar noch ein drittes
anschließen, wenn man das möchte. Eingangs, aber es können nur
zwei aktiv sein. Und die managt dann quasi,
dass der Traffic intelligent... Also Unifile
stellt.
Das wird bestimmt funktionieren.
Auch wenn ich kein
Unifile-Fan bin,
aber Funzen tut das.
...auf beide Fritz-Boxen verteilt
wird. Was mir übrigens auch noch einfällt, warum haben wir
nicht beide Karten vom gleichen Anbieter genommen?
War auch noch eine Überlegung. Wir haben uns gedacht,
wenn das Netz zum Beispiel der Telekom überlastet
wäre, hat man ja immer noch vielleicht ein entlastetes
netz der auto oder telefonika zur verfügung und dem schon einmal zwei
anbieter genommen hat wirklich vollen empfang kriegt weil wenn die vielleicht
bei der telekom oder linken kunde der zieht mit zwei karten total viel dann
draußen wir den malen kriegen halt zwei router nur 300 mbit aufgeteilt und so
ist es geschafft zweimal 300 mbit schaffen wir ab stream ist übrigens bis
zu 40 mbit gewesen bei beiden karten also telekom und auto formelt sich in
mikrotik rein da kannst du viel formeln router os hat 30 milliarden möglichkeiten
Leider ist die VLAN-Config irgendwie ein bisschen sackig.
Auf jeden Fall ist das für Carrier-Create-NAT blöd.
Kann ja Mikrotechnics führen, dass du Carrier-Create-NAT hast, oder?
Das Problem hast du bei allen Routern.
Wenn auf Anbieterseite nochmal NAT gemacht wird, dass du keine Ports weiterleiten kannst
und sowas.
Das geht mit keinem.
Oder was meinst du, was ist blöd?
Also MikroTik ist schon preis-leistungsmäßig mit das Beste, was man sich kaufen kann.
Inzwischen sind schon 600 Meter Kabel verlegt. Wir haben aber auch noch einige auf Lager bei.
Das ganze System ist noch nicht komplett fertig.
Erstmal schon wieder an Tobi ein paar Kabel crimpen lassen.
Das wird noch weiter. Der Kunde hat das in diesem Ausbau auch schon vor einer Woche getestet.
Da waren 1500 User da und da haben wir quasi festgestellt, es läuft gut.
Wir müssen aber die Position der Router noch mal etwas verbessern.
Die standen vorher da hinten. Da hatten wir zwei 5G-Balken-Empfang.
Hier haben wir jetzt drei bis vier, also vollen Empfang.
Aber jetzt mussten wir halt hier auch noch mal irgendwie knapp 80 Meter Kabel verlegen.
Und da hier über 2500 Leute erwartet werden, muss es jetzt wirklich perfekt sein.
Von dem Loadbalancer geht es dann in, zeige ich euch, professionelle Access Points.
Aha, UAP.
XG heißen die.
Die sind so gedacht für...
Ach ne, was für eine?
Hätten diese Dinger nicht immer irgendwas mit UAP oder so?
Professionelle Access Points von Ubiquiti.
XG heißen die.
XG.
Große Hallen, Stadien.
Es gibt die Dinger auch noch als Space Station heißen die dann.
dann also wirklich super hohe Leistungen sind da ganz ganz viele Clients gleichzeitig zu verarbeiten,
denn eine Fritzbox ist gedacht für kleine Büros oder ja zu Hause irgendwie 6, 7, 8, 10, 20 Geräte.
Die Dinger hier schaffen bis zu 1500 Geräte und davon werden hier drei Stück verbaut
und noch eine etwas kleinere Ausbaustufe der Ubiquiti 6 Long Range,
den wir hier in der Lobby verbaut haben und dann insgesamt mit diesem Konzept können wir dann an die 4500 User versorgen.
Das wird auf jeden Fall funktionieren.
Wir gehen mal eher realistisch davon aus, weil der Hersteller sagt, bis zu, unter absoluten Optimalbedingungen,
wahrscheinlich finden die alle ihr Handy unter optimalen Bedingungen, also direkt runterhalten.
Aber die Dinge haben richtig Feuer und die verteilen wir und dann haben wir ein großes Mesh-Wifi.
Das heißt, wenn jemand sich im Gebäude bewegt, wird dann quasi geschaut, wo ist der gerade, wo ist das Signal am besten
und dann wird das dann intelligent gemanagt.
Ja, und damit erreichen wir quasi, dass der Kunde sein Ziel erreicht und er kann allen eine schnelle Wifi-Verbindung bereitstellen.
Wenn sich jetzt einige von euch auch noch fragen werden, warum machen die das nicht einfach, dass die Leute da ihr Handy-Internet verwenden?
also wahrscheinlich ist der empfang hat nicht so geil oder weil da drin so gut wie gar keine
frage also wenn man glück hat mal so ein zwei balken lte aber auch irgendwann mal abbrechend
und ja das ist halt von innen irgendwie bisschen schwierig da empfang zu bekommen und vor allem
wenn mehrere zugreifen geht gar nichts mehr da gar nichts mehr ankam wenn leute da drin telefonieren
wollten aber unser wifi und so und auch die internetverbindung klappten wir mussten aber
damit rate limits arbeiten bei dem alten standort war halt der durchsatz nicht gereicht hat da haben
Wir haben jedem User 5 Mbit gegeben. Das reicht. Das kann man auch ganz unkompliziert darüber verwalten.
Ich zeige euch das nachher auch noch mal kurz.
Können wir mal drauf schauen, wie die Verwaltung aussieht, die Oberfläche aussieht, was man da alles mit machen kann.
Aber jetzt zeige ich euch am besten erst mal innen den Aufbau, das Setup.
Ich kann mich noch gut daran erinnern, als ich Tim das erste Mal traf.
Er war Anfang 20 und ich hatte kein Internet.
Und er nahm mich an die Hand und zeigte mir die Weiten des World Wide Web.
Auf einmal lernte ich meine Freunde kennen.
Dominikus Link und Dennis Weigelt.
Wir gründeten eine Familie.
Und jetzt sind wir, was wir sind.
Und das wäre ohne Internet, ohne den Herrn Biber, niemals möglich.
Oder ohne mich.
Oder wie wir sagen, mit Biber ist mir lieber.
Wir stehen jetzt hier, wo alle K.A.S. sind.
Morgen K.A.S.
Wir laufen zusammen in der Halle.
Hier unten haben wir die Dream Machine angeschlossen.
Die ist hier schön versteckt hinter so einem Banner.
War vom Standort am besten.
und um das provisorisch zu machen auch am einfachsten an dem Ort, weil hier haben wir Strom und alles, was wir brauchen.
Hier sieht man jetzt quasi die beiden Anschlüsse, die von draußen kommen für die beiden Router, 5G-Router.
Ein weiterer ist hier über einen RJ45-Adapter als Backup vorbereitet.
Könnte man also quasi umstecken, wenn man jetzt noch mehr bräuchte.
Oder wenn einer dieser Anschlüsse ausfällt, eine Leitung müsste neu gelegt werden.
Parallel könnte man das damit leicht realisieren.
Hier sind jetzt drei Access-Points angeschlossen, ein vierter wird noch angeschlossen.
Oder jemand drüber fällt und über das Ding runterreißt.
Da oben unter der Decke.
dort oben hängt einer und da hinten wird da noch eine angeschlossene verbrauchen
aber hier diesen steiger und erst gerade reserviert hinten kommt noch ein hin
haben also drei stück hier in der halle und kommt mal mit
wo ich auch noch was zu sagen
viele leute nicht wissen diese access points
sie sind für decken montage gedacht das ist nicht so nach dem motto nice to have
oder so da gibt es so ein pdf von denen wie so diese an welchem winkel die quasi da abstrahlen
und so und da sagt der hersteller bei den dingen diesen ex gibt welche die sagen sie
explizit für deckenmontage und manche sagen explizit für wandmontage und der beste empfang
ist tatsächlich wenn die dinger wie gedacht an der decke montiert werden
hatte ich ein bisschen schwierigkeiten bei mir hier
ich habe so gemacht weil an meiner decke da ist wirklich schwierig was
reinzuschrauben das ist so eine künstlerische decke die der opa damals
entworfen hat da kann man nicht wirklich großartig was reinschrauben
Ich habe es jetzt so gemacht, ich habe mir so eine kleine Halterung 3D gedruckt, aus so zwei kleinen Haltern, die man an die Wand schraubt.
Das habe ich quasi kurz unter der Decke an die Wand geschraubt und da drunter hängt dann mein Access Point hier oben.
Und der Access Point unten im Keller, der hängt an der Wand, geht auch.
Aber nur falls man mal daheim sich fragt, warum, obwohl ich jetzt hier so ein Ding stehen habe, ist es nicht gut.
vielleicht weil das ding unglücklich irgendwo in der ecke auf der auf boden
steht das ist nicht optimal es wird
wahrscheinlich zum größten teil gehen das zeug reflektiert ja auch ein bisschen
das wird schon gehen aber für optimalen empfang ist tatsächlich decken montage
bei diesen dingen angesagt hier kommt eine leitung an die wir
verlegt haben hier im boden gibt es so kabelkanäle und hier mussten wir
arbeiten wir einfach mit einem switch der quasi wie so eine art repeater
wirkt weil die kabelstrecke ist zu lang hier sind wir nämlich bei 100 metern
angekommen von der ganzen bis hierher die kabelstrecke und hier wird quasi direkt auch
noch mit p o e gearbeitet mit p o e injector das ist für strom und hier geht es dann weiter in
den jack des gebäudes wo wir dann noch ein access point montiert haben der ist auch schon aktiv wir
hatten eigentlich vorher gehofft dass wir das einmal mit einem weiteren connector lösen können
was hat nicht gereicht deswegen das ist jetzt provisorisch hier müssen noch die leitung ordentlich
verlegen dass provisorisch heißt es bleibt für immer so habe hier ordentlich hergeführt wird
und dann geht das kommt der deckel wieder drauf dann ist es auch zu jetzt gehen wir mal nebenan
gucken so dass hier quasi die lobby in der lobby wird vor und nach dem event dann kann man so mit
und gibt es hier und musik wird ein bisschen party gemacht und hier haben wir an der decke zur
abdeckung dieses bereichs auch noch ein nächstes point denkt da oben das ist der 6 long range der
quasi in verbindung mit denen die aus der halle strahlen hier diesen bereich abdecken soll und
das ist auch der den wir da jetzt quasi angebunden haben und ihr seht das ist alles natürlich nicht
super schön verkabelt weil der kunde hat er sagt also das macht keinen sinn dass alles schön den
kabelkanälen also zu verkabeln das ist halt wirklich jetzt nur für dieses event genau und
mit diesem setup erreichen wir halt in der gesamten area einen sehr guten empfang und
jetzt würde ich sagen schnappen wir uns mal laptop und ich zeige euch mal die einmal zeige ich euch
die performance die wir erreichen hier an dem standort und auch mal so ein bisschen das front
end von dem von der dream machine was man also einstellen kann so wäre es okay es unify das
Wir haben deswegen mal einen Speedtest gemacht mit der LTE-Leitung über Telefonica, also über O2 und haben hier ziemlich gute Werte erreicht.
300 Mbit Download und 52 Mbit Upload.
Und noch sind sie auch alleine.
Der Telekom-Leitung schafft man gerade so.
250 haben wir davor getestet und 40 Mbit Upload.
Das heißt, der Kunde hat so round about 500 Mbit im Download, die über zwei Leitungen verteilt werden.
Eigentlich ziemlich gut für Mobilfunk, oder?
90 Mbit Upstream.
Das ist natürlich keine Glasfaser-Verbindung, aber dafür, dass man hier so mal 16.000er DSL kriegen würde,
Das ist natürlich eine deutliche Steigerung.
Und wenn wir hier mit Rate Limits arbeiten, das zeige ich euch jetzt hier auch nochmal.
Das ist die Verwaltungsoberfläche.
So, sind wir hier verbunden.
Ich mag die Unify-Oberfläche nicht.
Ich kann mir da nicht helfen.
Die Leitung, die ich erkenne, ist gerade nicht ungewöhnlich, weil ich hatte gerade direkt angeschlossen.
Einfach um den Speed am Router zu testen.
Telekom ist auch gerade nicht angesteckt.
Aber hier kann man jetzt prinzipiell dann alles sehen, was wichtig ist.
Man sieht, welche Geräte eingeloggt sind.
Aktuell sind es gerade mal sieben Stück, weil ja noch Vorbereitungen hier stattfinden.
Man sieht, was für Traffic anfällt.
und man hat auch weitgehende Möglichkeiten, hier Einstellungen vorzunehmen.
Zum Beispiel...
Oh ne!
Jet, ist das...
Das ist irgend so ein Comedy-Gruppe-Typ, hä?
Dein Traumleben voller Liebe, Glück und Verlust beginnt mit der Sim.
Du bist viel größer als du denkst.
Boah!
Das ist...
Ja...
Wie die Leute, die früher in der YouTube-Werbung mit Porsche vorgefahren sind.
Das Mindset muss einfach, Leute, das Mindset muss her.
Der zahlt bestimmt gut, sonst würden die es nicht machen.
Die haben einfach...
Wie spricht man das aus? K-Man?
S, ja, Mann.
Ja, oh Mann.
Das juckt doch da keinen, ne?
Hochgesetzt natürlich könnte man jetzt nachher auch sagen, man möchte ein Rate-Limit einsetzen,
dass zum Beispiel jeder User 10 MB Download kriegt und 2 MB Upload.
All solche Sachen kann man hier definieren.
Man sieht, das kann ich euch nochmal zeigen, welche Geräte gerade verbunden sind, auch
in so einer Art Topologie-Karte.
Und sieht drei Access Points.
Ja, ob die Access Points auch das richtige Mindset haben dafür.
Viertens bauen wir ja noch an, genau, welche Geräte.
Man kann auch genau sehen, welche Geräte wir lassen.
Das Wifi braucht das richtige Mindset.
fall das bin ich in meinem macbook bin per kabel verbunden mit dem gerät und das ist auch ziemlich
praktisch und man sieht die wifi experience das heißt man sieht wie gut die verbindung zu
dem man muss einfach nur dran glauben leute dann werden aus 10 mbit auch 20 da kann man dann auch
noch ein bisschen nach justieren wenn halt erforderlich also spricht man kann noch mal
die kanäle von den access points überprüfen wenn das nötig ist wie kann man uns auch hier abrufen
hier sieht man jetzt die verschiedenen access points die wir haben nummer drei ist der vorne
in der lobby aktuell und die beiden hier an der traverse sind eins und zwei wahrscheinlich ist
jetzt hier jemand ja das ist wahrscheinlich der linux isos bettoren ziehen das natürlich alle
bettoren wird ja prinzipiell nichts anderes gezogen als linux isos logisch und auch noch
mal die wifi experience wie das ist die nutzung der verschiedenen kanäle da muss man natürlich
darauf achten dass es keine überschneidung gibt zu anderen kanälen und das ist halt ziemlich praktisch
wenn man das ganze auch machen kann oder darauf zugreifen kann wenn man nicht beim event ist also
sprich wir können quasi in unserem büro sitzen der kunde hält ja seine events ab wir können aus
aus der ferne darauf zugreifen und das alles optimieren man sieht auch ganz
schön wie traffic gemacht wurde sieht man auch teleautomation eingesteckt das
telekom kabel funktioniert nicht weil so wie ich gesehen habe benutzen 2,4
gigahertz nicht 5 was ich gar nicht so verkehrt finde weil von der von der
reichweite ist 2,4 deutlich besser als 5
vielleicht ist der hintergrund oder zwar beides an ich habe es bloß 2,4 da
gesehen
das liegt muss man gerade gucken wo ich das hingepackt habe ja hier dass das telekom kabel
da steckt noch nicht können auch mal gucken hier die latenzen werden wir angezeigt 19 millisekunden
24 35 finde ich für fünf gierig voll in ordnung kann jetzt bieters machen hier natürlich war es
vorher nicht angesteckt weil die ganze zeit rot es wird quasi auch gemessen wie die qualität ist
das internetanschluss ist die latenzen und so da kann man halt auch gucken ist der anbieter
den man da hat und ich muss sagen wir hatten vorher vodafone und bei vodafone war das halt
ziemlich schlecht das ergebnis da sind wir schnell zu der entscheidung gekommen dass wir
ist halt tauschen gegen auto das kann man ja auch ein speedtest fahren ich hoffe das geht überhaupt
nur einer steckt weil wir laut menschen haben hier sieht man auch 300 m mit erreicht jetzt gerade im
download knapp das finde ich halt super fett und wir sind jetzt auch im mobilfunk ist sehr
schnell ist und 42 40 m wird wahrscheinlich so rund um durchschnittlich 41 m wird da upload was
hier super wichtig sein wird für viele leute werden ja hier so ein bisschen ja sich in die
werden wahrscheinlich posten eben gerade bei wie ist der typ damian richter und
hab ja den krassen live was auch immer keine ahnung was die leute also schreiben
gerade das richtige mindset hier und da es wird voll los gehustet oder keine
ahnung was sie da immer so auf posten von solchen events steigern sich so ein
bisschen rein sage ich mal werden total gut gelaut und was posten wollen
von ks aller
man will ich das schon sehe
alter so eine motivation veranstaltete klatscht jetzt alle mal zusammen
monka ist es ist das tor musik
einer wie die da wie die da abfeiern
Apple Keynote sieht genauso aus.
Naja, komm, gar so schlimm ist es da nicht.
Da muss ich jetzt mal kurz gucken.
Wie viele sind da jetzt wirklich?
Hallo? Da.
Was haben wir denn?
YouTube, please.
Also die meisten Leute
Macbook
oder sowas, hä?
iPhone? Was heißt denn das da?
Habt ihr eine Ahnung, was das heißt?
Others. Others heißt das.
Others.
Ah, hier sieht man es besser.
Linux!
Ob das ein Android sein wird?
Aber die meisten Leute sind ja mit ihrem MacBook am Start.
Die machen schon ordentlich Traffic, die Leute hier.
Ach, Moment.
Speed.
Meister Traffic Speedtest.
Google. Instagram.
Natürlich.
Was ist Limelight?
Das ist irgend so eine
Plattform,
wo man seine Lifestyle Sachen postet.
Da ist es wichtig, dass die Leute auch schnell abloggen können.
Wenn wir das mit zwei Leitungen haben, 80 bis 90 MBit, finde ich voll in Ordnung.
Und soviel dazu. Also das machen wir auch.
Also wir sitzen nicht nur im Rechenzentrum, wir machen eigentlich jede Art von Netzwerk möglich,
ob es nun für Gaming-Kunden ist oder für Kunden, die einen Server brauchen,
Geschäftskunden oder auch halt eben sowas hier, wenn es ganz spontan sein soll.
Und ich betone nochmal für die Leute, die vielleicht es geskippt haben, das hier ist eine absolute Provisoriumslösung, die der Kunde wieder mitnehmen möchte.
Guck mal hier, die Kabel gehen einfach so hoch. Ist nicht professionell verkabelt, dass es ging. In drei oder vier Tagen musste diese Anlage ja aufgebaut sein.
Macht ja auch nichts. Juckt doch überhaupt keinen. Ist da hinter irgendeinem Teppich.
So, ich würde sagen, ich muss jetzt hier den vierten Access Point noch an die Decke bringen lassen.
Also ich fahre diesen Steiger nicht, muss ich sagen. Ich kann den nicht fahren.
Aber der Herr, der den anbaut, möchte den gleich anbauen und der hat nicht ewig Zeit.
Ich muss hier auch noch ordentlich Kabel verlegen und auch wieder einen Repeater.
Also lustigerweise Repeater.
Einfach einen Switch, weil damit kriegt man halt dann auf Strecken über 100 Meter hin,
wenn man alle 100 Meter so ein Ding einbaut.
Weil der das Signal quasi wieder verstärkt.
Ich weiß noch nicht, ob es irgendwie was professionelleres gibt so.
Weil normal hat man halt immer Unterverteilungen in den Häusern.
Da hat man eh einen Switch.
Ganz ehrlich, wenn es tut,
oder mit Glasfaser, weil das wäre jetzt hier auch für spontan mal ein bisschen zu teuer.
Und ja, so 50 Meter Netzwerkkabel gehen vom Preis. Also auf jeden Fall, da muss ich noch einiges machen,
muss noch einiges verlegen, verkabeln dafür. Ja, und dann kommt der an die Decke. Wenn euch das Video
gefallen hat, dann schreibt mir mal in die Kommentare, ob wir künftig noch mehr Videos dieser Art
veröffentlichen und erstellen sollen. Dann nehme ich nämlich auch den Aufwand in Kauf, dass ich bei ganz
vielen Kunden mal lieb frage für euch, ob ich da nicht die Kamera mitnehmen darf, denn das ist immer so ein bisschen problematisch, könnt ihr euch vorstellen, weil gerade bei Geschäftskunden ist immer Betriebsgeheimnis, Datenschutz, Wohlbefinden der Mitarbeiter, weil viele mögen sowas einfach nicht, wenn die während der Arbeit auch gefilmt werden, fühlen sich da unter Druck gesetzt und da ist es, also das ist...
Wollen nicht beim Reddit surfen, gefilmt werden.
Das ist auch immer so der Grund gewesen, warum ich es bisher noch nicht gemacht habe, weil eigentlich hatte ich schon Lust, es ist aber immer echt problematisch. Bei dem Kunden ist es so gewesen, der ist überhaupt nicht öffentlichkeitsscheu, das könnt ihr euch vorstellen.
Ja gut, wenn das irgend so ein Kreisel-Kreis, Mindset-Karriere-Coach, Lifestyle-Coach ist, für die ist egal, wo der Name auftaucht, positiv.
So Motivationstrainer, Coach, da steht man ständig im Rampenlicht, ständig auf der Bühne, für den ist das normal, wahrscheinlich sogar cool, wenn wir da quasi so ein bisschen Reichweite, kleine Reichweite vermitteln, die auf ihn aufmerksam wird, ich weiß nicht.
Aber auf jeden Fall, ja, würde ich das probieren, aber schreibt mir mal in die Kommentare, ob ihr von diesen Videos oder dieser Art von Video...
Könnt ihr ruhig mehr Videos machen.
von der netzwerktechnik bei kunden wenn ihr da mehr sehen wollt schreibt mir in
die kommentare dann würde ich mich bemühen dass wir da noch mehr
drehgenehmigungen kriegen für euch ja ansonsten hoffe ich dass euch das video
gefallen hat unterstützt unseren kanal mit endlich mal die 10.000 abos schaffen
mit klick auf die glocke und auf den abo button und ich wünsche euch alles gute
bis zum co2 gucken wir jetzt nicht chat ich muss jetzt auf
Schön, dass ihr da wart.
Spontaner Nachmittagsstreben.
Ich werde jetzt noch mein Toastbrot hier fertig futtern.
Und wir hören uns.
Macht's gut.
Nix ausstrieben, wir sehen uns, bis dann
See you